this is Jocko podcast number 231 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
also joining us tonight once again is
Dave Burke good evening Dave good
evening
so last podcast was with Dan Patterson
if you haven't listened to that he was
the first officer in charge of the top
gun weapons school in the Navy it's a
great podcast it was awesome to have him
on there and as I heard him talking the
entire time as I read his book which is
also called top gun an American story
the thing about top gun is that it's not
just a school for four fighter jet
pilots to go to there is a thought
pattern there is a mentality there is an
attitude and this is not the attitude of
you know that and it really we you know
we barely even talked about the movie
Top Gun on the podcast with him and
that's because in my mind I could barely
connect the two
I could barely connect the reality of
that original Top Gun school with the
attitudes you look there's some on the
Venn diagram there's some there's some
overlap of course but we're not talking
about the arrogant jet jockey we're
talking about the attitude of trying to
improve trying to learn and trying to
win and there is a giant overlap the
biggest overlap that I found the largest
overlap in the Venn diagrams in my brain
is well it's it's my kind of fundamental
core thought pattern which is extreme
ownership that's what it boils down to
is this attitude that
when you lose a dogfight and this was
very interesting when you lose a
dogfight you don't blame the plane you
don't blame the other pilot you blame
yourself you say okay this is my fault
why did I lose and how can I win and I
said that's something that has possessed
my life and I see all kinds of
comparison in there and I see the same
look that same mentality that ownership
mentality it's in good seals it's in
it's in a good jujitsu school it's in a
good business it's in a good team and
it's in good leaders and as as as it
relates to the SEAL Teams part of this
is when we started using simunition and
we'll get into it when we started using
paintball whatever you want to call it
simunition slash paintball laser tag
this multi-million dollar laser taxes
and that we have when you add that in
here and you can start dogfighting you
figure out if you're smart if you take
ownership you figure out how to win UFC
jiu-jitsu look no one really knew who
was gonna win a fight between a karate
guy and a wrestler or or a Kempo guy and
a jujitsu guy no one really knew who is
gonna win until the UFC until people
started to fight or whatever valet - -
and Rahzel whatever you wear whatever
you want to go when people start to go
at it when people you actually engage in
combat and then you ask yourself why did
I lose why did I lose and and when you
ask yourself why you lost and you don't
blame it on the guy was bit think of how
easy that would be in jiu-jitsu hey the
guy was bigger than me the guy was
stronger than me the guy was faster me
those are the reasons why my system
didn't work it's this excuse it's that
excuse it's another excuse instead of
saying you know what I didn't win let's
figure out why I didn't win and then
let's make some adaptations and so the
I thought about this and I said it you
know as soon as he left as soon as Dan
left I was like oh we're gonna have to
go deep on this stuff Dave because the
better you know the better
I can understand what it looked like
from your perspective I think it just
opens up a better understanding of this
whole mentality so let's talk top gun
and let's talk fighter tactics and let's
talk winning and owning and making
mistakes and learning from mistakes like
this is how this is what the winning
teams do there was some really
interesting points when he was talking
about Boyd and he's saying Boyd is
saying this aircraft beats that aircraft
which if you think about it just like we
talked about with extreme ownership if
if I say oh that aircraft is faster
tighter turn or whatever then mine and
that it's not my fault that I lost
instead of saying hmm
what can I do to win how can I win and
to me that right there that's the
difference that's the Top Gun attitude
that's the extreme ownership attitude
it's not my planes fault it's my fault
and by the way if you deliver me a plane
a military industry if you deliver me a
plane that doesn't function correctly
what do I need to do take ownership of
that and say let me give you guys some
feedback here's where this is true
here's where this fails here's where
this doesn't work here's where the
shortfalls are if you don't have that
attitude you go up you know what we
don't have a good enough plane oh well
they they they didn't they didn't get it
right oh well we're gonna lose now oh
well that's the attitude of blaming
others and you never get better
yeah I could talk all day so this is a
cool subject for me
I'm in just first things first with the
the the mentality of Top Gun is I
learned more humility at Top Gun as an
instructor than anywhere else that's
where I really started to learn humility
which is someone
you think about it from the outside kind
of counterintuitive it's also connected
to what you talked about with the movie
is the closer you get to Top Gun the
farther you get away from the movie and
to the point that there is literally
zero connection because of course it's a
movie but when you're kid you see it and
it sort of represents some idyllic thing
that looks really cool and it puts you
on a path you want to go do that and the
more you learn about it the more you
realize it's it's just a movie Top Gun
breeds more humility because of what is
going on at Top Gun the Charter for Top
Gun is even more daunting than the
Charter for being in a fighter squadron
so we're in a fighter squadron you were
supposed to be ready to go to war you're
enough operational fleet squadron it's
find no different than being in a team
your job is are you ready to go to war
the Charter for Top Gun is to train
every single fighter squadrons leaders
to lead their most junior pilots into
combat and that's a that is a big big
deal so when you talk about am I doing
this right or doing this wrong it isn't
just how good am I or it doesn't even
really just how good the people around
me are is if it what I'm doing impacts
the entire the entire friendly US and
Allied air forces across the entire
globe and that's a that's a huge charter
and and that that generates a lot of
humility because you recognize what does
you're doing and it's really hard to
understand that until you're on the
inside when I got on the inside of Top
Gun I realized what a what it really
meant to be an instructor you know a lot
of weight on your shoulders and you have
to deliver did you feel the same
attitude of being the people that were
responsible for preserving the
capability of aerial combat did you feel
that was there was there a sense that
hey this is on me yeah you you you are
part of a legacy and you are you're one
of the people in the line that's
currently working in that line and you
you have three years that's what you're
gonna get the obligation that you feel
to preserve the legacy and then make it
better which is also pretty daunting cuz
you look back in the history of talk and
I think man how am I going to contribute
to this and not just sustain it but
actually improve
you feel that from day one there is a
lot of history there and it's not just
history to feel good about it its
history to give you a sense of what you
were part of and what they expect from
you it's also I've never worked so hard
I've never put in so many hours and I've
never been more solely focused on one
thing than I did in those three years
even in the fleet there was a little bit
of a balance when I was at Top Gun the
balance was skewed so far towards and
I'll just say walk just to be to make it
simple but the balance was so far skewed
towards Top Gun that I honestly didn't
do I don't think I ever did anything
from Monday morning at five o'clock in
the morning till Friday night at
probably 6:30 7 o'clock on a Friday
night those are the short days Friday
afternoon was a short day everything I
did was completely connected to work
everything and I imagine when you
compare that to being out in the fleet
out in the fleet you got other things
going on right you got manpower you got
administrative things that are happening
you got whatever deployment cycle and
schedule and all this other kind of
administrative stuff that just is
totally gone in here at the top gun the
fleet is cyclical so you have a workup
phase and you have focused on this work
up a new prep and you have deployment
phase and that's a huge amount of focus
and you come back and you kind of have
you know a bit of a let down phase you
lose some people they go elsewhere you
get some new people on board and it
cycles and the pace cycles up and down
the responsibility's cycle up and down
and what you're trying to do changes all
the time top gun is a bullet train it
has been since 1969 you get on that
train and there's no cycles there's no
downtime there's no post deployment none
of those things happen so you're just on
that train all the time and that train
is just moving and it never really slows
down where when you're in a fleet
squadron I did for my first four years
in a fleet squadron this cycles all the
time depending on on what you're doing
and that those cycles don't exist at Top
Gun so when you went to Top Gun for the
first time as a student yeah how long
had you been flying an f-18 for I
started flying f-18s I can get this
right in early 1998 and I got to Top Gun
in 2001 so you were kind of a
I was on the the the younger side in
both time and and flight time so time
and time and fine
total time and then time in an airplane
so I was a more junior guy there are
certain qualifications you have to get
and one of them was called a division
qual which is leading for airplanes or
more that's a requirement to be there I
got that call I think like the week
before I showed up to top down so I was
really junior to be going you know not
unprecedented but I was much more on the
junior side and more on the
inexperienced side when I got selected
to go to the course and how did you get
the nod and not someone else you know I
mean some of it's a bit of a numbers
game yeah every fleet squadron roughly
has about 18 pilots and it varies but
the math is typically one person a year
is gonna go so in your three years that
you're in a squadron you know maybe for
three or four guys you're gonna go now
sometimes you get two in one year none
the next because you're deployed but it
kind of works out to worn a year but
there's also a you know a kind of a
window of where you can go and I
probably was competing with maybe 10
guys it was not all 18 no some of the
squadron commander summer guys are there
not really in the window to go so over
those 10 you know peers that you have
you're gonna probably see one or two of
those in your peer group go during your
time in the fleet and it's based on you
know your performance it's based on how
well you've done up to that point
there's a bunch of qualifications you
get you've done one deployment at that
point I had done one deployment and they
log every landing that you do on the
courier and it's all graded everything
and so you had whatever a bunch of tens
and some nines and some other guy had a
bunch of tens but out of eight and they
add it all up there's a little more
subjectivity to it probably the biggest
event is this big culminating event in
the fleet and the Navy the Marine Corps
do a very similar similarly is when you
get what's called a you know an a CT air
combat tactics instructor qual it's like
the big workup to kind of fully qualify
you as a combat flight leader and it's a
huge process and it culminates with this
kind of week-long evaluation where an
instructor from the weapon school comes
out and you fly with this person for a
whole week and it puts you through from
beginning to end II put you the whole
thing at the end
he kind of determines a if you're a call
and then he goes to your squadron
commander and basically says this is how
this kid did compared to the dozens and
dozens of dozens that I've done
personally as an instructor and the
hundreds and hundreds that we've done as
a weapons school and they kind of tell
the squadron commander where they think
you are
in their experience and the feedback
that my a CT instructor gave my squadron
commander was enough for my squadron
commander to look at all the other
things he had and then get this external
feedback to say hey I'm gonna send Dave
to Top Gun do you guys dogfight in like
your regular squadron yes you're going
against each other yes you're and how
many guys in the regular squadron have
been a Top Gun before mmm I think when I
was there the first time there were two
patch wearers in my squadron so of
eighteen guys I think two had we're top
congratula and they can kick everyone's
ass pretty naturally yep they're pretty
much so you get the nod you go when you
when you show up there do you have any
inkling in your head that you're gonna
do well that you're gonna be able to
hang you're just like you don't know
100% that you're getting in with a black
in with the Sharks in with the black
belts yeah so I I don't have a feeling
that I'm not gonna succeed but I have to
be totally honest I don't have a sense
that I'm gonna go that I'm gonna
dominate I don't walk in there and day
one thinking I'm gonna crush this place
I wasn't afraid of failing and you know
I've had that feeling in different
places I remember going to OCS the first
time thinking oh man I might be in over
my head here but I had no sense of how
long in OCS probably a week it took me
about a week to figure it out at OCS
first week was just kind of a state of
paranoia like I'm not supposed to be
here I think I made a mistake I'm in
over my head
did you not know what you were getting
into I didn't I did kind of sort of but
I didn't quite get it until I got there
all the things leading up to OCS were
just a whole bunch of administrative
things that get you there's like
paperwork and interviews and
applications and GPA and all it's just a
bunch of stuff all it is is on pit you
know you have to run physical fitness
test and show that you're qualified but
nobody had ever I never replicated that
experience at all so reading utter loss
of freedom of any kind complete utter
loss of freedom and then
but what kind of shocked me for me at
OCS it knows a little bit of a detour
when I got to OCS I looked around and
everybody looked the way they looked
they all looked bigger and stronger than
me and it kind of made me think like oh
man I'm supposed to look and be I'm
supposed to be six foot one and and 210
pounds that's what I'm supposed to look
like and I didn't I was 18 at OCS I mean
I was small and and I kind of told
myself that what I was on paper wasn't
who I was in real life I've never really
been tested I've never been put in a
situation I didn't think I can handle
and I get to OCS and 36 hours after you
get there you're on the first Platoon
run and I'm like I can't run this fast
I've never run this fast in my life
how is everybody running this fast I
remember looking around thinking this is
nuts I had enough fortitude in my mind
to not quit and the thing that helped me
the most about OCS is the first time
somebody else quit and the first time I
saw somebody else quit when I got over
the how weird it looked to see somebody
quit that actually was a little little
fuel for a little little help for me and
in the first week people are quitting
left and right and every one of those
times was help me and go hang on a
second I can do this until I got to
point like this is no factor and the
latter half of OCS was almost fun I'm
not gonna say fun but he got pretty
close and by the end of OCS I thought I
was 10 feet tall but I that was the only
real time in my life that I went
somewhere in the Marine Corps like I
don't think I should I might have made a
mistake here and I proved myself I was a
good test for me so I didn't feel like
that at Top Gun I didn't feel like I was
in over my head but I felt like I was in
a big big big ocean and I was a pretty
small fish and I wouldn't have to work
really hard to get by so how long is the
top gun school 10 weeks a little bit
over 10 weeks but it's basically a 10
week school okay so how many flights are
you doing a day in the beginning you
kind of plan on two and then about after
the first third of the program it's
typically typically one a day one flight
is an hour hour and a half flights
themselves or about an hour
11.1 is what you're gonna flog for
flight time for etapa one flight a day
for five weeks first first first couple
weeks as you said is to two flights a
day yeah so at first week is academics
then you do about two weeks of kind of
to a day then you get another academic
kind of thing in there and then you're
typically for the last half of one
flight a day how many how many air
combat duels do you get in an hour
so when you're fighting one against one
you're gonna get probably four sets we
call them a set is one engagement why
don't you start to finish
you could get four sometimes five and
then you know depending on it goes maybe
three or four is about right okay when
you when you start off you just had one
on one that's where you start is one on
one yeah me against you yep that's where
it starts that's right and I would think
that because then the next thing you do
is two against one
right yeah is that right that's right
who's the other who's the other there's
one bad guy and there's two good guys
the other good guy is a Top Gun pilot
correct or sorry a student yes so when
you go out two against one
it's you with an instructor Oh against
an adversary god also an instructor okay
yeah
most of the fights you do up until the
end the really heavy phase the one
against one and the two against one is
you or by yourself or you were with an
instructor as your wingman okay well I
that's see I assumed it would be you and
me as students against echo the
instructor and we would go out there and
beat them up there are a couple fights
like that but most of the flights your
wingman is your IP your instructor and
that's because we if it was two
knuckleheads out there we just wouldn't
we just wouldn't get anything right it's
nothing wouldn't get anything right it's
that the closer the instructor is to
what you're doing the more he can help
evaluate your performance and give you
the feedback that you need okay so you
go out let's say I go out I'm the
student you're the instructor we go out
we dog fight against echo we do three
dog fights for dog fights it takes an
hour we come back
and and look I've heard you talk about
these freakin debriefs right what what
are you telling me as my instructor in
these debriefs what are you telling me
and how are you telling me the things
that I'm doing wrong is it just
cold-blooded because look we all know
that you know more than me and I just
fully accept it and I'm like all yours
is that pretty much where people are at
yeah for the most part look I mean I do
not want to understate that their ego
the ego is out there and it see it's a
Top Gun it's there as a student the ego
is usually connected to kind of the fear
of being exposed as not as good as you
are as opposed to the ego of I think I'm
better than you and so the ego reveals
itself in different ways but for the
most part most people get there pretty
early on and the disparity between the
students instructors is so great that
people aren't really that afraid to just
be brutally honest now people aren't
jerks about it but there they are
brutally honest and you figure out very
early as a student the two things you
figure out is it's in your best interest
to identify all of your own mistakes and
your instructors mistakes you know if
you can identify those two because it
reveals that you actually know what's
going on the other side of is if you
don't the instructors pretty much don't
miss anything
so if you have a thought like man this
is really minor I'm just gonna kind of
not talk about this it's gonna get
brought up and it's always better for
you to bring up your errors then have
somebody else bring them up for you and
that gets ya it gets in your head pretty
quick so when we get back from this
thing I'm gonna go through the debrief
first I get to kick it off cuz I'm the
student yeah that's real hey I turned
too tight there I didn't use enough gas
there I didn't know where I was for a
second over here I lost track of you my
wingman here this is so this is the same
thing at when I was running trade at we
would let the platoons debrief first
like okay guys you tell us how it went
and usually the platoon chief will kick
it off and he's gonna hit a lot of stuff
the good ones will the bad ones same
thing that we either covered up or even
they don't even know what just happened
they don't even know what mistakes got
made and you know so the platoon chief
goes then maybe the the platoon
lieutenant goes and he doesn't see as
much usually as the chief but then the
the task unit senior chief might go and
he's gonna see more and then the task
unit commander you should get pretty
close and my goal every single when I
was going through training with my task
unit my goal was like the instructor
cadre will be silent because there will
be nothing left we're gonna rip our
selves apart so hard that the instructor
cadre is gonna go actually guys it
wasn't that bad yeah yeah that was
always my goal so so that's where we're
going yeah and are you having to teach
me okay so if you were coming to our
desert warfare training and you're a new
lieutenant the first thing I'm gonna do
is okay I'm gonna say okay here's
maneuver number one here's maneuver
number two here's maneuver number three
here's my new number four you got those
basic four moves right you got four
moves that you're gonna do is what a
contact front you know the enemy is out
front here's what you're gonna do you're
closed terrain oh the enemy's out front
you're an open terrain it's a different
move but there's there's a there's a
basic number of moves that you're gonna
go through that's where we're gonna
start is this what's happening or do you
already know these moves yeah when you
show up to Top Gun as a student you know
all the moves you you have to have
demonstrated some proficiency in all the
moves to even get there give me an
example of let's go let's just teach you
a couple moves yeah so and you know at
this point I'm gonna call this if you're
not watching this on YouTube I'm
imagining you might start moving your
hands around a little bit and just which
is you know cool with me but I don't
want to keep saying the whole time
trying to describe what you're doing if
you start talking with your hands which
you might maybe you won't but teach me a
couple moves right now yeah so when you
start in the the what we started the one
against one phase so it's pretty
straight forward is your airplane and my
airplane same exact airplane you're
flying it as a student I'm flying it as
an instructor and like you said before
each phase the instructor will demo a
brief but after that the flight lead and
the person running it is the student he
runs the brief he runs the flight and he
runs the debrief and obviously the
instructors there to support through it
but the first set of moves would be when
we call offensive BFM which means I
start
behind you 1180 fm sorry good question
basic fighter maneuvers so offensive BF
m is the first flight you do which is
one against one and I am being set up by
design in an offensive position to fight
to dogfight you so we're gonna do a
dogfight and we're gonna set it up on
purpose that I start behind you and so
I'm gonna put you in a defensive
position and I'm gonna put me in an
offensive position and the only real
objective there's kind of three
objectives is the first thing I need to
do is I can prove that I can stay behind
you which is gonna require me this is
you're the instructor I'm the student
okay I think as the lead you wanna be
yeah yeah let me the student easy as I'm
gonna have more dumb questions perfect
so I'm the student you're the instructor
yes
the first thing we do is I'm gonna start
behind you is that right no so I got it
backwards so if we're gonna do offensive
BFM you're the student you're gonna
leave the flight you will be offensive
starting all day so when we start the
flight and we do those we do those four
sets all four sets you will be behind me
I'll be the instructor and your job is
just is to maintain that offensive
position and the moves that you're gonna
do during that there's only like three
moose the first is called an offensive
break turn which means that when I react
to you is a defender and I don't like
this because you're over my shoulder and
I'm gonna try to shake you you have to
show the timing and the sight picture to
maneuver your airplane to stay behind me
and then the next move might be is that
you have to be able to do a maneuver to
avoid flying into the ground and we have
a simulated ground so here we say 5,000
feets the ground you have to do another
maneuver that you can show me that you
can transition down to the bottom of the
of the of the flight of the of the fight
and the deck correctly and then the last
move you might be trying to do is that
you can put yourself in a position to
employ a weapon now you know how to do
all those things you know how to do a
break turn so um yeah a break turn is
I'm turning my aircraft that's it you
turned yours are you doing like a shock
and jive here where you go a little bit
in one way and then you break another
way is there anything like that that's
not like that there's not so there there
is that because we're keeping it basic
no it's because there's actually kind of
a science behind it and there's in each
situation especially in this rudiment
one against one there's essentially one
optimal way to maneuver your aircraft
and it's different if you're defensive
than if you're offensive but as a as an
offensive so I'm offensive as the
student or you're offensive as a student
you don't have like 14 different things
you can do as a matter of fact you kind
of have one and what you needed to be
able to do is do it exactly right
because if you're one second too late
ten knots too slow or any number of
other variables off you're giving away a
chance for me to get away from you so
for you to stay offensive and keep that
offensive position I've given you you
have to perform that maneuver correctly
does the defense you guys shuck and jive
a little bit not to be quite honest to
what the defensive guy does is pulls
directly at the offensive airplane pulls
right at him
closes the space as much as you can
tries to create some space
limit the space and then I'm gonna
maneuver away from you based on how well
that you do your turn and if you do it
right all day eventually you're gonna
end up in the same place that you
started and I will not respond by like
you said shocking you're driving or
maneuvering until I see what you've
noticed so you're just being nice I am
flying my airplane the best way that I
can until I see how you respond to that
and if you do it correctly then I'll
have to start doing other maneuvers but
if I just break into you and just pull
my airplane right into yours really a
hard turn we'll call it a break turn and
you as the offender are really late or
screw up the timing or go too fast or
miss the cues to do it and there's not
much for me to do I don't have to do
much because you've given away that
offensive advantage so you're flying
flat dumb and happy I come in behind you
yep and you're just gonna at some moment
boom you're gonna turn left right or
whatever and I just have to track you
and stay behind that's exactly right
it seems very simple it seems very
simple do you even head fake right
because I can I see can I see your head
and your canopy so the way the the
ranges that we start are typically a
half a mile a mile and a mile
that's the preacher well just so you're
way way way out there you actually for
most of those you know at least the
start you're using the radar as a cue to
determine that range you kind of have
some eyeball calibration but the head
fake against someone who knows what's
going on and all it does is just give
away more advantage the head fake
doesn't help you the best thing you can
do is just break hard max performance
what if I was a big you know and I was
going after you what's the best thing
I'm on your channel what's the best
thing you can do the same things exact
same thing they don't kid tactic so we
apply are the ones that we'd use in the
real world how is it not good to give a
little shock and then go the other
direction because what that does is that
creates separation between our aircraft
and if I'm offensive and I'm the guy
attacking on behind you
I want separation to be able to maneuver
employ my weapons saddle in the way that
I want and adjust the situation the way
that I'm looking to have it be offensive
for me if you minimize that separation
create a bunch of closure meaning we're
now closing the distance I have a whole
bunch of maneuvering I have to do to
manage that closure which I don't want
to do so when I'm on defense
I want you closer to this when I'm on
defense I want you closer to me it's
correct okay interesting interesting
just like jiu-jitsu your optimal
position on offense is to have their
back because they can't see properly
they don't have any weapons that shoot
backwards right no you're right sir you
sir just like jiu-jitsu you want to you
want to get the person's back yes so
that's where we're at so so this is
Manute this is day one and we're doing
this so all we're doing so that's one
move you just taught me one move I'm
sorry it took so long know I'm not the
smartest guy in the world the first
thing you teach me is a I'm just gonna
break and well now it's I'm I'm gonna
break and and you're gonna follow me
okay what's the next move moves too so
teach me three moves yeah here so so
remember you're the student your offense
right now this this is easy I'm ready to
be a taco I got to do is break through
you kidding me
let's do this like
well the interesting thing about the
offensive break turn that I just taught
you the percentage of students that get
that right in the beginning is zero zero
and the percentage of the time that you
get it exactly right meaning you've hit
all your parameters is even by the end
it's still really low now you've
narrowed your error window pretty pretty
pretty small but even just this simple
when do i do my turn and when do I
identify all the cues and know exactly
what to do and exactly how to make it
happen just doing that very first move
is almost impossible for a student to do
correctly the first time so I let's say
well I said oh what about a head fake
right if I'm in the offensive position
behind you I can see the very first
indicator as soon as I see your flaps do
whatever they move a little bit and I'm
on it yes
the quicker I react the better I stay
with you yeah the more you can observe
an and there's multiple cues out there
it's the angle of your airplane it's
whether or not your afterburners have
opened up it's your angle over the
horizon it's how quickly you're moving
it's whether you're rotating or
transition through the sky there's a
whole bunch of cues out there that you
have to better identify in real time as
you're moving typically four hundred and
something not so the closure is
happening really fast you have seconds
to get this right you call it closure
but we're both moving in the same
direction right not when I break back
into you so if I've got this guy behind
you I'm behind you and you break you're
breaking in to me you're turning into me
creating even more closure so picture me
picture you flying around and you look
over your shoulder and you think and you
don't realize this now all of a sudden
you see somebody's there they're behind
you and they're a really good position
to shoot the only place for you to go to
keep him from shooting you is towards
him because if you continue straight
ahead or just kind of maneuver around
left and right I just stay back there so
you have to get you have to turn back
into me to close that distance guess
what that's exactly like for sure man
exactly like jujitsu yes right uuugh as
long as you're looking away as long as
they have your back you're doomed so
your goal you
to turn back towards them that's right
it's weird for me I think conceptually
because this is taking place over a long
distance right yeah like I when I'm
trying to turn back into you it takes
how long does it take to turn back into
him a minute thirty seconds no seconds
thanks yeah so it you will go from the
time that you say fights on which you
would which which you would say and then
I would start to turn into you if you
did nothing and just flew straight ahead
I would be past you in four seconds hmm
I did a dogfight in an f-18 I did a
bunch I did a back seat right up in
Fallon and I did a dogfight I did a bomb
run it was really cool but one thing and
I saw and did with the pilot guy was you
can fishtail is this right Who am I
perceiving this correctly like we turned
like our wingman or whatever turns so
hard you could see them fishtailing
totally through the sky yes so I guess
that cuts down your amount of time that
it takes to turn yeah and that's a cue
you have to be able to see that and
perceive that and if he's doing that
maneuver that indicates how fast he's
going it indicates his angle of attack
it gives you a whole bunch of
information about what he's doing you
need to be able to perceive that that's
happening you can act in your own mind
you can figure is he turning a small
circle a big circle you can calculate
all those things in your brain as that's
happening that is a cue that you need to
know in that other airplane as he's
doing it are you getting taught these
cues specifically yeah you know the cues
you know the Moose the planes are being
flown in such a precise and aggressive
way that they that they are hard to see
and that's really what the debrief is
about is dissecting the cues that you
need to figure out in order to maneuver
your airplane optimally it's probably no
different than jiu-jitsu if you were to
give me your back and say hey we're
gonna start Dave I'm gonna give you my
back and all I want you to do is
maintain that that position how long do
you think he would take you before I
couldn't keep your back
it would probably a matter of seconds
yeah pretty quick yeah but if you said
hey as I start to lower my shoulder and
I put my I want you to kind of bring
your hip towards me and you show me
now there's probably 20 other things
going on but now I got that it's gonna
add another two seconds before you
before you out maneuver me now
eventually you will and then you show me
something else and they got and now so
the goal is for me to incorporate all of
those little individual things together
and the eventual goal is that I've
started in this office position and I
never give it up mm-hmm
did so that's one move that's one move
one move
what was it what's the new fence to
break turn-off offensive break term turn
what's the next move so the next move is
when me is the instructor figure out hey
you're doing a good job my defensive
turn here isn't gonna work for me he's
just gonna stay behind me is gonna shoot
me I'm gonna do something else you kind
of called that I'm gonna shuck and jive
um as a defender gonna maneuver my
airplane in a different plane of motion
that first move didn't work
you followed me and if I keep going
you're gonna shoot me so I have to do
what's called a ditch which I'm gonna
now point towards the ground and change
this two-dimensional fight into a
three-dimensional fight complicates the
problem for you gives you a different
thing you got to deal with and now you
have to figure out how to chase me not
just two dimensionally but three
dimensionally and you're gonna have to
follow my ditch and we just call that
simply a ditch follow there's different
terms for it but it's can you now take
this two-dimensional flat fight and be
as effective in a three-dimensional
fight which introduces a whole nother
level of complexity
now we're going downhill and this is the
big thing that Dan kept talking about
depending on the aircraft that you have
on the power that you have we're gonna
go from horizontal plane to vertical to
vertical plane and so this ditch move is
the first the first movement into
three-dimensional out of the horizontal
plane into this other plane that's
exactly right that's exactly I mean that
seems pretty straightforward it does
seem straightforward all of these
maneuvers are straightforward how what
altitude you out when you with some
what's the minimum altitude above ground
that you can start this maneuver at this
ditch depending on the airplane a good
rough number is between three and four
thousand feet before you think hey if I
go much if I'm much lower than that to
the ground and I do it I have a pretty
good chance to hit in the ground you
need several thousand feet to do it okay
third move
the third move is that when I get down
to the to the ground the floor you know
we call it the deck but you're down
towards the earth we now have to do a
deck transition which means that now I
can't mover them in vertically anymore
because if I keep going downhill I'll
hit the ground so now I have to
transition back a new 2-dimensional
fight and preserve my position in a two
dimensional fight with the ground as a
component of this fight now which was
not a not a factor up at altitude this
means you're you're having to just gain
altitude again is that what we're doing
the the goal is to do one of two things
either
I now can gain altitude above him or I
can push him out in front of me and stay
behind him either one of those work for
me but I need to have some separation
from from the person I'm fighting so I
can employ my weapon I can't shoot the
guy at 0 feet away from him I have to
have some distance between us I can
either have that distance above him or
behind him just like jujitsu just like
this more moves into MMA where if you're
trying to hit me I want to close the
distance get close to you where your
strikes won't really make a difference
yeah the parallels are are I mean there
might be some differences in terms of
like the physical locations of the
machines against it with the people but
the parallels are thinner exactly the
same as in as a person who's offensive
if you think about finishing somebody
and the way I'm gonna finish is through
a strike which is kind of similar to
what these weapons are I need to have
some distance between you and me to make
that strike effective now there's a
distance that I get to close those
strikes just don't work there's also a
way that if I get so far away the
strikes are ineffective or it actually
allows you to strike as well and so I'm
constantly managing managing those those
separations and distance and if I'm
defensive and I look over I see that
person's in a great place to just throw
a punch at me I can either try to get
away from him which almost never works
at that distance although there is a
separation that you might try to point
but at that we started off was like hey
you were starting in a place that we
know running away won't work
so that range of a half a mile a mile
it's designed to say the escape option
is not available to you so the only
other
is I gotta close that distance to you I
can't let your strike be effective and
I'm gonna wrap you up as best I can to
do that that's the defenders job so
what's this third move called the Dec
transition Dec transition but it sounds
like there's multiple options on how you
transition from the deck there are and
all those options are all accumulating
they're all an accumulation of how
things have played out the entire way
from the beginning of the fight down at
the end of the fight so remember I
started that fight 6000 feet behind you
I'm a mile behind you if you do
everything right and I do everything
right guess where I'm gonna be at the
Dec transition um I'll be here six six
thousand feet behind every model behind
you and I'm gonna I'm gonna be good to
go but if you've done a better job than
I have I've missed some cues I'm a
little bit late I'll lose 500 feet here
I'll lose 75 feet here I'll lose a
thousand feet over here I'll lose
another 50 feet here and each one of
those moves that I'm doing down to the
floor you've chipped away by the time we
get down to the floor you know where
that fights against top interceptors
usually end up either zero or worse the
defender has become the attacker which
happens sometimes
so that's 6,000 feet it's pretty
uncommon to be able to preserve that
distance against the top gun instructor
from beginning to end and each part of
the fight in each maneuver that's being
executed you're gathering your fighting
for that distance again apologize I'm
the student you're the instructor I
start off 6,000 feet behind you when you
break turn you do it successfully
you're now closer to me yes and then you
break turn again and you're even closer
to me yep and you break turn again
you're even closer than you ditch and
you get even closer and then finally you
either are so close to me that you're
behind me that happens what what's the
other thing if you don't get behind me
what if we're just now we're really
close so just realize obviously we're
not gonna get so close that we're gonna
hit and so the distance of going from
6,000 feet a mile to being something
less than that if we were 0 feet apart
we'd be parallel right beside each other
we wouldn't be 0 feet obviously the
airplanes have a safety bubble between
but when we transitioned down on the
ground I'd look across and instead of
being directly behind you
I'd be directly beside you and I'd have
no way to shoot you just looking at you
side-by-side we'd be in a completely
neutral position where nobody could
shoot the other person and I've given
away an entire mile of advantage that
you gave me or that I that I gave you at
the start as the student okay
we're doing good I mean it's there's
there's something still a little bit
hard for me to understand at this point
you to you to echo Charles a little bit
but I guess so cuz I keep going or are
you gonna keep remembering that the
distances are way far away like you know
when you watch the Top Gun it's like
they're like right third they're
shooting each other and you know but
they're like super far away but they're
also kind of not because it's only a
it's a second or it's two seconds or
whatever to travel that mile well the
best thing I could do other than explain
this better would be to erase from
everybody's memory the movie Top Gun
because that's where your head's going
this isn't gonna work
well yeah cuz you're like hey close the
distance I'm like okay close the
distance but then yes you got to
remember as well that there is no
because essentially like okay like in
jujitsu or MMA where it's like green
zone meaning safe zone if you're too far
away from the guy who can't punch or
kick you whatever um green zone when
you're close he can't punch and kick
your fare but there's the red zone which
is that distance right so in if and
correct me if I'm wrong if I'm trying
understand this to where that initial
Green Zone the out-of-range Green Zone
that's not an option in this particular
drill or what is it what is it is it
like ten miles 12 miles the separation
if I'm on your tail how far away are you
from me that I bet you're not in danger
miles yeah several miles yeah and that's
not an option for this particularly
right design this one I went to one
phase we build it where you running away
at the start you can't do it okay just
go faster than me so you start we start
on behind you you're in the red zone yep
and you want to close the distance get
close enough to me that I can't find my
wife that is that other green zone right
the close Green Zone yeah well he's
behind me Mike
is to they take that 6,000 feet
separation and make it zero yeah or as
close to it as I can get yeah it's like
closing the distance in jujitsu basic
don't you okay don't you when you hit a
break turn and I'm slow doesn't that
make me further away from you no because
I'm turning back towards you you're
behind me I'm rolling my plane and
pulling it directly into your plane and
I'm literally gonna point right at you
as hard as I can and take whatever that
I can get whatever that six thousand
feet is and close as much distance as I
can as fast as I can and I'm not gonna
get much but I'm gonna get something
what's the turning radius of an f-18
it's totally airspeed dependent but at
the speeds that that we're talking about
the turning radius is probably 3,000
4,000 feet dang that's tight
yeah well when you're slower it's much
tighter the slower you get the shorter
your radius is okay and so even that
point that you made about the turning
radius that's a massive calculation
you're getting deployed right there I
have to know what your airplane is
capable of doing at 18,000 feet at 400
knots in full afterburner because it's
different than what your a plane can do
at 10,000 feet at 250 knots and it's
varies in every three dimensional plane
at berries and I have to figure out I
have to be able to just determine what
your airplane is capable of doing and
base my maneuver part of my maneuver
based on that that's why these simple
moves are so complex in terms of
implementation getting it right because
there's so many things going on because
even your physical ability in your
aircraft changes based on your altitude
and your speed it's constantly a
variable it isn't your f-18 just does
this every single altitude every single
airspeed every single throttle position
has a different output capability that
you're you're able to generate dramatic
differences yeah it's very dramatic what
an airplane can do at 15,000 feet versus
100 plane can do at 5,000 feet is
dramatic difference or centage wise just
rough percentage-wise
you probably
have your turn radius - probably a third
the size let low altitude then it would
be up at altitude so instead of you're
talking three to four thousand feet
you're talking closer to and I'll just
keep a generic but you know a thousand a
1500 window much much much smaller okay
so we get done with our first three
engagements on my first flight mm-hmm
I did I did it of whatever job you know
I did a pretty crappy job cuz no one
does it the first no that's right okay
so now we come back in for the debrief
and what do we look are we looking at a
dry erase board or we hit are we picking
up the little planes with the sticks on
them both you're looking at a
straight-up dry erase board with colored
pens do we have video yep and we got
video we've got the what's called the
HUD view essentially the first-person
view of the pilots view of both aircraft
do you replay like the radar as well or
not really not on the one on one
dimensional yeah well it's not that it's
two-dimensional it's that you know
there's only one aircraft so in terms of
how you're managing that system is not
that important when you account for how
well you shot your weapons you might
look at that but 95 percent of what
you're looking at is just the altitude
and the airspeed and the angle of attack
of each airplane through that pilots of
you okay so now your debriefing me how
much do i as the student how what
percentage you go okay Jocko what you
see up there you've got how many points
do you have on your checklist the stakes
that I made instructor 20 okay how many
do I get how many do you say you tell me
to debrief how many do I and I'm a
humble guy yeah and I have a good
attitude and I'm trying to give you a
good percentage do I get do I get 7 do I
get 10 I was gonna say 5 or 6 on day 1
you're gonna get 5 or 6 you need to get
the big ones you're gonna get the big
ones again you've know these maneuvers
you've been flying f-18s for three years
you've been through a training course
you're gonna get all the big ones for
the most part you know here and there we
some folks kind of get overwhelmed but
for the most part you've got the big
ones you're now doing an assessment of
me like this is just in your own head
because are we paired up for the whole
time we're at topic on is it you and me
no no
but you're gonna see me yep five more
times eight boards on whatever the
numbers you're looking at me and you're
going yeah or you're going mmm
guys got some potentially not bad is
that based on my experience is that
based on the time I've gotten the
aircraft is it based on hey this guy's
got a little natural ability yeah I
think it's all the above man it is I've
listened to you talk about this when you
first lock up in jujitsu and you you
don't know a hundred percent of this
other guy but you know a lot right away
like right away it's the exact same
thing almost on that first turn when I'm
the instructor and I'm looking over my
shoulder on your very first break turn
I'll get about 75% of what I need to
know about you in that turn and
sometimes it's like oh man okay it's got
lots of learning yeah and that sounds
like damn that was that was pretty good
and you can feel that in a very same way
in an airplane it does not tell the
whole story
but it gives you a really good cue and a
really good indicator of who that person
is in terms of flying the airplane and
that's a big part of it but I am much
less concerned about how well you flew
your machine I am about how well you can
explain what happened and so the debrief
is still a huge part of what my
assessment is about you and I won't
really know what that debrief is gonna
be like until we get in there but if you
show me if we lock up and I feel like
you're in the game and you fly a really
good airplane I bet you the deeper is
gonna be really solid if I'm out there
with a kid who's all over the place he
can barely keep his plane where it needs
to be it's very likely his debrief is
gonna be just as bad you know what's
interesting is this I'm thinking about
this idea of when you lock up with
someone on the jujitsu mats of justice
yes sir you could lock up with nine
different types of people and they all
feel totally different but the
indicators that you're getting are
providing you with messaging that you
have to have a high depth of knowledge
to understand my clear examples you get
the guy that's just super strong right
and he's super strong so you feel all
this tension but you know as soon as you
lock up with him you go oh he's strong
he doesn't know what he's doing right
like that's crazy that you can sense
he's really strong but he doesn't have
jujitsu you lock up with someone that's
all lanky and skinny and pale and just
and you lock up and they're weak they're
weak and you lock up with them and you
go uh-oh this guy's got some skills you
can tell that when you lock up even
though the the messaging that you're
getting to your brain is totally
opposite they're totally opposite and
the occasional you get someone that you
lock up with you're like oh this person
strong and they know jujitsu this is
gonna be fun this is gonna be a
challenge but it's interesting that you
can gather all that from we just you
know what that lock up and maybe a
little bit of you know a little bit of
movement I'm in talking to seconds of
movement 3 seconds movement you're like
okay ah this is gonna suck this is gonna
be hard or okay I'm gonna weather the
storm here this guy's strong but he's
nobody's doing that that's a I don't
know if that's completely unique to
jujitsu and maybe you're getting guys
that they do do you notice do you notice
that level of understanding based on
this guy's you know initial reactions
you get a you get a good read the way
you described it I think is exactly how
I would describe it you get a good read
it's it it doesn't determine the outcome
you don't know everything but and those
are for in alcohol it the fruit you sit
first three or four seconds it's really
the first one or two turns you watch a
couple of turns out of a guy you know
what you're dealing with for the most
part and you know what a good turn looks
like and you know what a weak turn looks
like and if a guy gives you two weak
turns you kind of know how it's gonna
play out what does a good turn look like
what does a bad turn look like a good
turn versus a bad turn is a good turn is
his his angle towards you is exactly
where it's supposed to be there's no
- hi or no - lo it's exactly on the
plane that it's supposed to be down to
the degree you're like wow like he gave
me he gave away nothing in that term
because I can oversteer you can you can
oversteer you can understand that's
right you can do both you can pull not
enough you can pull too much you can
overturn you could under turn you could
be a little late on your after burger
you could be a little early on your
after burger and get going a little too
fast and it opens up your circle even
bigger which gives me even more room and
so the margin of that of the four or
five things that you're in control of
you got it now hold on yeah you just
said it gives you more room it gives you
more room because I hit I thought you I
thought you wanted to have more room oh
no you want to close okay I got it I got
it
no um it's definitely confusing to me
yeah and and I need to kind of maybe as
we keep talking I'll try to
there's a lot of what we're talking
about here in this warn against one
that's that's really cool and and
reveals a lot of things but it's a
really small part of what we're asking
folks that do a Top Gun and what you're
really trying to Train - and I need to
just explain it a little bit simpler
simply and and and and more rudimentary
in a way that hey what the objectives
are so that as we talk more about what
Top Gun is it'll make more sense it's
just it's not quite as simple as I want
to close the gap and you want to close a
gap what I'm really trying to maneuver
to her is a place where I can employ a
weapon and now there's like this weapon
has this minimum max range this weapon
has this minimum max range and I might
try to start for a gunshot but like
that's gonna be hard so maybe I'll
maneuver to a missile shot
well this missile has this envelope well
I'm outside of that but this missile has
another envelope so there's a lot of
overlapping things I think the biggest
takeaway is is that in order for me as
the defender or you as the attacker the
offensive airplane for either of us to
succeed in our role the margin of error
that Top Gun is really small the
capacity to identify your mistakes and
those errors is what the real test is
and that happens in the debrief but you
can fly a plane against another aircraft
and look over the horizon a watch you
fly I could fly against you and
I can tell from the way you move your
plane through the sky how good you are
and I can see it and I can feel it and I
can watch it and I can calculate it and
I can most of the time in the first two
turns tell you exactly how the fights
gonna play out now if you show up and
you give me those first two turns are
every bit as good as mine now it's like
man I don't know how this is gonna in a
real fight student gets the structure it
just doesn't happen yes they just can't
bring that level of capability and that
performance
you're never contemplating the outcome
you're mostly contemplating how well
they minimize their errors and how well
they optimize their performance to give
away as little as possible okay so in
the debrief you're like hey you know I
you you pull too hard here's what
happened look right here here you see
you see this you pulled too hard yeah
that's why I'm drifting out of the
screen or whatever cuz you pulled too
hard yeah is this something I go okay
cool got it isn't it is it a relatively
easy thing for me to note and I'm
learning it it's like yo I mean in
jujitsu I'd say hey echo you know you're
you need to get you squeeze your knees
together right on an armlock hey you
could have done better but you your
knees were loose squeeze your knees next
time and that's something he can
actually start doing like access next
armlock he tries it again and boom he
tightens knees and he gets it so this is
a similar level of Correction and
ability to to make those Corrections
yeah it's almost immediate because
everything I'm telling you you
understand I'm not teaching you a
concept and I'm not showing you a move
that you don't know I'm revealing a
little bit of an error that you know I
hate what you did here was just I hate
you need it you need to have your hips
here and you need to have your arm here
but you you get that like oh man I can
actually recall that my hips weren't
where you said that makes sense not that
I'm seeing this and typically the way
you would have that work is hey do you
think your earlier or late on this entry
here oh I'm super late I'm like yeah why
do you think you're late well first I
saw your airplane kind of move which
tells me I'm late but I also look up and
you're doing this airspeed 470 hey you
know if you're doing 470 you should have
turned already right so what's the key
like hey
I need to start this turn sooner and I
need to look for different things and he
can go out in the very next flight and
almost immediately make that correction
so that's good so where we're at right
there is I like I caught this I saw your
airplane move so I knew I was late I've
said this about jiu-jitsu if you have to
think about the move you're too late
if I take a second if I go oh Echo's arm
is available right now I think I'm gonna
go for it he already defended it I had
to have felt it and and acted on it
anything that's exactly the same thing
what do you see
yeah what do you see what's a little
indicator that so the indicator is if
I'm far enough away as you're turning so
you're offensive if I'm far enough away
and you're watching me and you're
looking for a cue on when you should
start your turn if I'm far enough away I
kind of just appear to just be rotating
in this guy because I'm so far you don't
see it you don't see the lateral move
you don't see my airplane moving across
this guy almost appear to be stationary
but the closer I get and you can picture
this like seeing something far away it
doesn't have a high crossing rate and
it's something like a car you look at a
car a couple miles away you don't see it
moving back and forth and as it gets
closed you see this movement back and
forth it's a lot easier to see what we
tell people is you look for the cue that
when he stops being stationary in the
sky and starts to move across the sky
you're at the range of which you should
start to turn your airplane the problem
is is I'm sitting and staring you're
going okay I'm waiting for him to move
and waiting okay I see him starting to
move and then you're late and so it's
that visual cue of rotating to
translating through this guy which
occurs at an exact range it's it's a
mathematical range of which you can see
that you have about a second to
restitute to be on time and if you're a
second early or a second late you've
missed that window and if you're looking
for it it's too late you're you're
looking for the attitude is that the
right worth the attitude of the aircraft
no you're looking for the the way the
aircraft moves I would call it the
crossing rate so if I'm five miles away
from you and I'm staring at you mm-hmm
you could be moving pretty aggressively
but I don't have to move my head to keep
up with you you're so far away you're
just a little dot you're just moving the
closer I get the more it's obvious I
could oh he's actually moving back and
forth you know these really small turns
actually the closer get are huge turns
and so at some point the turn of you
rotating through this guy actually
appears to be moving across the sky got
it that range I'll say it roughly a mile
just keep it simple that's the point at
which you can you can that transition
from rotating to moving that's about at
that mile and you have to know where
that is as soon as that happens you have
to start turning and I'm I'm teaching
you to look for that now you already
know that's you already know what that
is you can explain it you can teach it
but it's the ability to do it against an
aircraft moving as dynamically and as
aggressively as I'm going to be when
you're fighting me is where the
challenge comes from and to prepare for
this to come to school a lot of the guys
you've been flying with don't show you
the optimal maneuvers they show you a
pretty good mover but not an ideal
maneuver and that's just cuz their lack
of ability they're just not as good and
you know you've talked about when when
guys like Dean trained to go fight in
the UFC they don't just have one
training partner they have one guy who's
exceptionally good at maybe this one
thing he's really good at grappling
maybe this guy is really good at
striking maybe this guy is really good
at jujitsu and he's gonna train to be
really good at all those things as
opposed to just constraining partner
while he's a little weak in this but
he's my training partner hey if my
training partner has some strengths here
but he's not great here you're gonna
show up to Top Gun and we're talking
about this one particular skill you're
gonna get overwhelmed alright so how
many flights do we do like this where
we're just one-on-one five six do you
ever go as the instructor do you ever go
on offense or is that just too easy or
is that part of it that's part of it
that's that's the next flight the next
flight yep once you you don't let me get
another crack at the title well if you
if your fight is so bad that you
couldn't even stay behind me we're gonna
go do it again but as soon as you prove
to me hey
you've demonstrated that you're good
enough you understand what's happening
that you can maintain this offensive
position we'll move it on didn't you say
zero people execute a good turn zero but
that turn so a marginal turn still keeps
me in the game you're gonna have four
different sets so I'm hoping that each
one gets a little bit better
mhm if you have one of those three
ranges that wasn't gonna have you do it
again hey let's do that 9000 foot one
real quick let's do it again
so show me one more and if you're in the
window and then in the debrief you can
really explain to me what your errors
were and I truly think that you
understand what those were or I don't
need you to go do it again if I finish
the debrief and I can tell your loss I
can tell you don't really know what
happened and you didn't really execute
and can't explain why we're gonna go
refi that until you do it again how many
out of ten how many would you have to
reload out of ten pilots how many you
have to reload and say you know what
eight oh
maybe nine nine out at night Mike my
class
why'd you say is the next flight we're
already doing something else that it
sounds like we need to do this yet again
well what we skipped is something I
mentioned you once before
most of those reloads you don't even get
to the debrief we do what's called an
immediate reef lie we land we go back
and I say Jocko don't take off your
flight gear mmm-hmm sign for this
airplane we're going right back out and
doing don't you want to tell me what I
did wrong I'm gonna and in the time that
it takes to walk from the airplane to
maintenance the sign for the airplane
and go back to the airplane in that
fifteen minutes you're not gonna talk to
the entire 15 minutes oh hey I want you
to start looking for this you're
consistently late look for this cue pay
attention to this hey I need you to slow
down relax you're going too fast here
you're going too slow here take it I'm
gonna give you three or four things to
think about I'm going to go do it again
and that's usually enough to get you to
kind of get back your composure and get
back to doing again and my first when I
went through as a student only one
student in my class got past the first
flight on the first try one was his name
Dave it was not has been pretty I was
they were a bit it was pretty epic it
was not me I was lucky enough that I had
one REE fly and it was that very first
flight I read through that first flight
on immediate
reply and I never roof light again which
was which was kind of crazy did you kind
of want to get more refined so you get
more time flying no I didn't I wanted to
pass the flight on the first try they we
could tell the story some of the time
but I got plenty of flight time but I
wanted to pass I wanted to do well
enough on my first flight to pass that's
what I wanted to do when I was there
okay so now we finished with this one on
one yep what's well we finished with the
first flight now so I was on offense now
you're gonna go on offense and I'm
trying to shake you yeah you're gonna be
on defense we're just gonna swap roles
and all I'm doing is doing a freaking
tight turn that's it there's no shock
there's no dry jive there's no it seems
why is it seem like that just like I
could do something a little bit better
yeah like how come you guys couldn't
think like me yeah I mean I I think did
you Jitsu parallel is probably pretty
good if you and I are going out there
and I'm like just gonna and I just start
getting wild with you and just tow these
crazy things and and I'm trying to throw
these crazy moves your way to try to
shake you is it really gonna be a
problem for you no it's is it gonna make
it easier for you yeah yeah it's gonna
make it easier than if I just do like
exactly what I'm supposed to do and
there's sort of one or two things that I
really have to do I have to put my body
in this place I have to put my weight in
this place for this to work and if I
don't have those two all the other stuff
that I'm doing for you is like what are
you doing man like it's almost like this
it's just it does it does nothing but
make it easier for you to attack my
position that being said if you're on
defense as the instructor you can do a
break a ditch a deck a deck transition
and then another break and then another
like you can pile these moves on top of
one another right oh yeah I mean this
happens multiple times in a flight yeah
you're doing ditch and ditch and ditch
and the that's happening several times
it's not just three moves that those
moves signing that several so those are
the moves that
yes the moves are those move so in
jujitsu
there's a really easy way to explain the
escaping them out right when you escape
them out you can either basically you
can either oppa the guy over your left
shoulder over your right shoulder you
can me escape or you can elbow escape
the right there right leg or your or
their left leg right that's you can go
in any one of those four spots and you
know this is actually Dean Lister
material you can go you so you have to
try a first when it doesn't work you you
can try B when that doesn't work you can
try C when that doesn't work you can try
D when that doesn't work you go back to
a but the way you actually escape is a d
b c d bc b d DB a CPD boot mirror that
that's what so this is the same thing
yeah when you said hey teach me the
moves I'm making it simple there's
basically three moves now you you are
going to apply them throughout that
flight but you're not gonna come up with
like oh man I'm gonna come up with some
crazy thing that he's never seen before
it doesn't work and it actually it makes
it worse for you so if you're mounted
and I'm trying to get you off and I just
am flailing right I'll roll over on my
stomach or do some as the offender just
like dude you're not helping here go
just do a really the best thing you can
do is just do a breaking that's right
best thing isn't the best thing you can
I see you do is do a break and then do a
ditch yeah and then do another break yep
and then do another net yep and then do
another break yeah you you owe em you're
out of moves by the way the three moves
yeah I mean and and listen son sometimes
you can't do a ditch if you're too close
to the ground the ditch isn't an option
it's not available to you if you do it
you will die period so it is not in your
repertoire do you how much do you use a
change of pace like in basketball you
know when you're dribbling down the
court you change pace you go you you're
going fast and you slow down for a
second then you go fast again is there
any of that yeah not really is that
because it's too hard to control the
rate of speed of the aircraft in a short
enough time that it will make them react
to the proper way yeah I think that's
that's a big part of it and
and so getting from fascist slow is
pretty easy getting from slow to fast is
harder and so the change of pace to me
is more about I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
get some airspeed back let's say I'm
going 200 knots and I'd love to be
forging knots I can't just go from 200
to 400 so I'm gonna gotta go to to 220
and that may take a second and I'm gonna
steal about 20 knots and then we're
gonna swirl around a little bit and then
I'm gonna see an opportunity to Jocko
gave me a little bit of room here
I'm gonna go from 220 to 250 that'll be
3 seconds boom I got and I'm gonna steal
that and I'm gonna get to fit and I'm
gonna so that change of pace is me
trying to steal but if you ever apply so
much pressure to me effectively that I
can't do that I don't get that speed
back and you can actually fly an
aggressive enough airplane to keep me
from doing that then I don't get to just
steal that to dictate the pace so the
pace of that of changing air speeds it
comes in a pretty big cost and so you
have to do it really intelligently and
when you do that and steal it every
chance you get what about when Dan was
talking about going vertically yeah so
there's a really unique thing that they
discovered a top known they talked about
the egg about there's a vertical fight
is the way your airplane maneuvers
vertically going from pointed up so
pointed high to low is a your airplane
is typically very slow at the top of a
loop which makes sense you lose that
energy to get up there so the slower you
are the smaller radius is so the tighter
you can turn but you also have something
we call God's G so it is pulling you
back towards the ground so the radius of
your current at the top of a loop is way
smaller than your radius at the bottom
of a loop because you're fighting
against G going from low to high G is
helping you going from high to low so if
there's ever a place where you're above
someone and they're below you and all
the other factors are relatively even
your tongue at the top is better than
his turn at the bottom and it's
typically a more advantageous place to
be and so the key would be is how can I
maneuver to a place where I can climb
above you without putting myself at risk
to your weapons and then maneuver above
you and take advantage of that
three GeForce that's available to me
going from high to low or you're
fighting against that and you're losing
it going from low to high and that's
kind of the goal of that vertical fight
that he described sir was that something
that you would do yeah I mean that
that's something you could do so he he
brought up an interesting thing and you
mentioned this with Boyd I think the way
you said it was exactly right man
so f-18 f16 f15 mig-29 su-27 all these
airplanes in this generational world
that I was in at Top Gun during that
time they're all pretty good and you
know what the f-16 is a little bit
faster than an f-18 but the f-15 is a
little bit better turned race and it's
no different than hey maybe you're
stronger than echo but echoes got you
know a little better flexibility and
maybe you've got some capacity that he
doesn't but none of that is exclusive
meaning you don't get to just beat him
because you're stronger because he can
counter that strength that you have with
something that maybe you don't have so
on paper all these airplanes have
different strengths and weaknesses but
none of them are so absolute that you
get to just beat me because your machine
is better than me it's always always
always comes down to the pilot depending
on what type of plane i'm flying against
that vertical move is an awesome move
some airplanes it's the last thing I
want to do so I won't go up there at all
when Boyd's comes to his conclusion
wasn't our aircraft in Korea worse than
the other aircraft in most ways yes most
of the ways in how was that not just a
red flag that hey actually it depends on
what the pilot does well in boys defense
boy kind of understood that Boyd had the
way Boyd explained it when he talked
about eeehm theory that then Dan was
talking about he explained it in
somewhat of a different way he also
evolved into a different airplane The
Phantom but Boyd make no mistake Boyd
understood that just because your
machine turned faster climbed higher
didn't mean you're gonna win
Boyd understood that without a doubt
because we know that there's other areas
that we're stronger it
other neurs that we're stronger in and I
can actually assess in real time how
well you're performing your aircraft so
I can observe go hey your airplane can
actually do this but you're not making
it do that hand so guess what you're
essentially giving that to me so the
strength on paper that says you know you
can jump this high well in theory you
should have that extra three or that
three or four inches that you can jump
it I can't but you're not jumping that
high and I can see that and assess that
I'm gonna take that from you and I make
that your advantage is no longer your
advantage so how does Boyd then get to
hey don't fight a MIG with a f4 phantom
I mean the way I perceive that is a
failure to recognize a how much training
matters how much how critical it is to
be able to observe all these tiny little
nuance things that by themselves may not
appear to be a big deal but if I find 20
of them in a fight and I put them all
together it's a massive advantage and
what this what what science says an
airplane can do isn't the limiting
factor now there are some limits but
when you build an e/m diagram you don't
account for Dan Patterson's tailslide
it's not in the e/m diagram it's not in
the science because the science says the
airplane is no longer flying and these
guys are like yeah that may be true but
watch this I can go pure vertical to my
tail the airplane slides back down I can
pitch it around with my rudder none of
that is in the diagram and I can make my
airplane do something the paper says it
can't and when I do to you you will not
know how to react and I'm gonna kill you
so that combination of the mentality and
the mindset with the recognition that a
fight is 20 things pieced together and
all of them together is how you get to
the outcome is why Top Gun is what Top
Gun is if I'm if I'm looking at that
okay like I just don't understand how I
don't figure out that I can beat a MIG
with an F for if I know well let me
think we take one step further how do
the engineers not know this how the
engineers not say
hey here's how here's what you can do
with one of these aircraft in that era I
think the way Dan yang describes it is
they didn't they didn't have the right
mentality these airplanes were not even
designed to be dog fighters there was a
they were convinced that that arrow was
over that's kind of like guys like in
the Air Force guys like Robin olds are
such a legends because in the face of an
entire industry and in the face of an
entire era of of the military mindset he
recognized that the value you know the
thing that makes us better is how well
we train and how how aggressive we are
with our machines not what you tell me
the machine can do and that's why guys
like yank and the dudes that start a Top
Gun and guys like the Robin olds of the
world that's why those guys are
legendary because they fought against a
trend that said this is a machine that's
not designed to turn if you turn with a
MIG you're gonna lose it's like well
we're turn with MiG's and I'm not gonna
lose so I'm gonna figure this thing out
and some guys did and that was the
origin of Top Gun is when everybody was
saying you can't do this he said not
only can we we have to and that's pretty
cool the the other I'm just thinking of
the test pilots right cuz cuz those guys
are taking these birds and the the
engineers are saying it can do XYZ and
they're taking it way beyond those
limitations especially in that era
that's what I'm saying yeah because
nowadays maybe with commute computer
modeling in AI you can maybe get a
little closer but back then it was like
okay here's the bird here's what we
think he can do what do you got dude
those guys back then in the Jaeger era
those guys were getting the airplanes
didn't even know if they were gonna fly
I mean what they knew on paper versus
what was gonna happen there was a big
gap there those test pilots of that
generation you know that right stuff
generation I mean they were doing crazy
things and having in the discoveries
they made and what they are able to do
now there is so much more modeling so
much more science behind it that look
there's still a community out there
they're doing incredible things but
typically when you strap on an airplane
you have a
good idea of how it's gonna perform and
how it's gonna be him nowhere near like
what they were dealing with in that era
how did you feel when you when you were
flying the f-22 and the f-35 how much
were you saying hey you guys told me XYZ
let me give you the real numbers over
here from from good deal yeah well that
that was kind of my life in the Raptor I
was an operational test pilot so not a
developmental guy that's that you know
there's developmental test which is
literally they build it and they wanted
to go see if this thing works
our job is once they've figured out the
Machine work which is the Raptor
operational test pilots go out there and
figure out how to use this thing and
operationally test it in operationally
relevant environments so not the science
but the operational piece of it and you
look you had to know the science you had
to know what the airplane could do
mechanically but the coolest thing about
being an operational pilot was taking an
airplane like a raptor and then finding
everything you didn't like about it
everything you thought was wrong about
it everything that the science said it
was good but you knew wouldn't work in
combat and we got to identify and fix
those things and that was awesome
because you took this awesome machine
and put it in in relevant operational
scenarios and you beat the crap out of
it to see how it would do give me an
example unclassified of like hey you
took your Raptor out and you said you
know what you need to make some
adjustments over here and I mean I know
the acquisition systems in the military
is like crazy
would you get real-time fixes on these
birds yeah some would get pretty quick
you know we had to do a lot of
prioritize and execute back when we were
doing operational tests so we'd get this
airplane it'd have we'd have this list
of 30 or 40 things on this tracker of
all the things wrong with it and
oftentimes what we thought was the
number-one problem would take the
longest it cost the most money but
problem if I have six and seven combined
were less than problem one and they
could fix it in a matter of days and so
we hit problem five six and seven and
got really quick turnarounds and made a
ton of incremental changes that over
time over to three-year period
completely change the capability of the
airplane we didn't always get everything
we wanted we'd always get all the money
we needed and we'd always have time to
make all the fixes but we had a really
cool feedback loop with the engineers to
fix the things that we said were
important and make it fix it really fast
okay I'll run you back to Top Gun all
right you're putting me through training
yep and you're judging your echo and me
okay and you you get your first lock up
with both of us you do your little
assessment what prioritize next cute
what's the number-one differentiator
between echos top-line capability so
you're gonna get echo you're your new
goal is just a trained echo and trained
me to be as good as we possibly can get
what is the what's the quality that
you're like oh echos good at this he's
gonna be able to excel in in this and
he's gonna do a little bit better better
than chocolate cause I can't eat
chocolate laughing in his ability to X
yeah I would say recall from cuz it
remember I'm teaching an instructor I'm
teaching a teacher here my job is to
make you and echo teachers in this not
just how to fly the airplane behead
teach flying the airplane is recall can
you tell me what happened all the things
that happened and recall is connected
very closely to something we call
situational awareness so do you really
know all the things that are going out
there in three-dimensional space with
all the airplanes in real time the more
you can process what's happening the
more you can recall what's happening the
better you are gonna be able to teach
this and understand what actually is
it's going on you could be really good
in an airplane and maybe a little bit
better than him just pure moving that
machine around but if you don't really
know what's happening around you the way
that he does eventually he's gonna out
he's gonna outperform you so it sounds
like I need to have the ability to
detach I would agree with that did you
identify that while you were in the in
top round in the Marine Corps did you
ever identify like hey oh I can see this
guy gets all wrapped up doesn't know
what I'm little this guy over here he's
you know he separates his brain from his
body and what's happening and he can see
the big picture yeah I mean what did you
call it we used the situational learners
well the determined situational
awareness when people lost situational
awareness or no
longer did what you just described we
just call it we'd say looking through
the soda straw I mean which is very
similar to you know I think you guys use
a phrase front sight
well front sight focus isn't the best
because front sight focus is a positive
thing right because you're doing it in
order to aim a gun we say you're your
target fixation but then we say you know
you're staring down the scope of your
weapon which that is exactly what you're
talking about you're looking at it
through a straw
same thing yeah and I think it's just
just same different phrase same exact
meaning what that typically meant is
that echo or you whoever's looking
through the soda straw would just start
to stare one piece of information and in
airplane you got a whole bunch of things
going on inside and outside of the
airplane plus you're hearing things so
you've got all these different inputs
and I could tell when you are echos
looking through the soda straw without
even seeing you because I'll say
something to you and you either won't
respond
you know you'll respond really late
you'll do something wrong you know I
hate this you know I hate this because I
know it's on video right it's on video
like you're like oh here's me calling
you you know here's me calling you again
here's me calling you again and I'm
going oh yeah no I was not detached it's
crazy what do you tell me so we get back
I was staring through the sort of straw
what do you tell me eight what's your
deep before it and then what's your
what's your corrective measures that
you're gonna give me when you're looking
through the soda straw yep so the debrie
on with a flight and looking through the
soda straw didn't respond to your calls
I missed a bunch of stuff what do you
tell me so the way I'm gonna have a
pretty good idea in the while we're
flying around that you're doing that and
I'm gonna know cuz you're missing calls
you're not going the way you're supposed
you're not hearing things or not doing
things but when we get back the first
thing I'm gonna do is say hey tell me
what happened on that flight which is
just draw it out for me just run me
through what you saw and that is the
standard debrief the first thing we do
is recreate the flight and you get a
marker you get up in front of the flight
you get red pins and blue pens to get
good guys and bad guys and you just need
to draw we started here we went here you
started here and and that maybe two
airplanes that maybe 16 airplanes but
I'm gonna need you to just show me your
recall and that's gonna be my first real
indicator other than me Washington real
time that you've missed some things and
so after you draw it up and just
say this is what happened then we're
gonna put up the tapes so before I get
into your and say hey you missed this
and missed that what I really am gonna
do is give you a little bit of a chance
to now watch the tape and go ooh hang on
stop tape for a second I drew that we
went off to the north and turned here
with this group but I'm watching the
tape hey that didn't happen now I isn't
a shocker no okay that's a really good
sign jakka maybe it wasn't all together
there but Jocko can self-assess he's
detached in the debrief and he's he's
self aware the likelihood they're gonna
go out and get better on the next fight
is actually really high and I don't need
to give you a ton of debrief and I might
reinforce and go hey that's a good catch
man listen for the audio on the next
call did you hear the call that there
was a manoeuvring in the north and he
was like nah man
Jaco says he missed it okay these are
all good things if you draw it up
clearly you're missing things you run
through the entire tape and don't make
the connection now you and I need to
start back over then I need to draw
what's up there and I'm gonna put some
some big circles on the board and go hey
we're gonna really analyze this
engagement here and I'm gonna play the
tape ago okay stop what do you see
where's this airplane what did you
depict it now I'm gonna show you that
you miss something and I'm gonna have to
kind of run through that whole thing in
detail with all this data to show what
happened to try to get you to realize
that you're messing things and the what
I'm gonna tell you moving forward is
you're more likely to start to lose
situational awareness after we get past
to this face so once the first turn
happens you tend to get too connected or
too engaged or two more sighted on this
thing
and I can start to figure out what
triggers you to get emotional what
triggers you to get more sighted what
triggers you to look through the soda
straw and they start to call this out
for you and get you to think about it
before we go do it and then see how well
you can adapt to that how well can you
actually pull yourself out of that
detach and we'll go do that again and
see what you do in the next one so I you
know because you're not in an airplane
because you're you know in a fake urban
environment or you're out in the desert
like this is a conversation I had more
times than I can count with a young
leader hey man you're you're all caught
up in this here's what you need to do
you need to put your weapon in high port
you
to take a step back off the line you
need to turn your head and look around
yeah
so it's see it seems like that is a
clearer form of instruction it's an
actual thing that you can do because
it's a different environment is there
anything that you could give them more
directly to get them to take a step back
put their head on a swivel look around
detach is there anything better that you
could tell them your I see what you're
doing with hey here's all the things you
missed and I did that too I would do it
with my little pocket recorder and we
had these laser guns
we had these laser tag system and they
had little GPS is on them and those
little GPS is would track where you are
and then we could replay the whole thing
on Google Earth and these guys would
have no idea I didn't know my element
was over there I didn't know this guide
to it so that's the same thing that's
the same technique of listen man you
didn't know this Elam was over here you
didn't know that the assaulters already
left the building and you didn't see
where you didn't know this stuff was
going on and they go yeah I need to I
need to pull back but then I'd say
listen man you need to get off your gun
you need to go to high port you need to
start looking around you need to start
paying attention to what's going on big
picture is there any instruction you can
give like that while I'm flying it an
f-18 it's pretty uncommon that in the
middle of a training flight that I as an
instructor I'm going to give you cues to
do the things that you're supposed to do
there are a few exceptions but I mean I
could do it after the after the OP I
mean this is always I always like ham
right there I'm after the OP I'm going
bro oh you can't let this happen here's
what you need to do all the time - all
the time and that's sort of the beauty
the tapes you know one of the crazy
things is the way that the tape machines
used to run before is the cameras would
be kind of connected to the canopy and
record the screen and in the reflection
of the screen you could see the pilots
head literally see his head and I go hey
listen every time we're approaching a
murderer than ten miles I can see you
staring at this display at ten miles so
what I want you to think on this but
every time you get and and the reason
ten miles important is that we had a
radio call that would
say somebody would say ten miles and he
wouldn't be hearing that call ten miles
is the call that's telling everybody
start looking outside start literally
looking up and out so you can stop
looking your screen and start finding
the actual airplane itself hey I want
you I want you to give the ten-mile call
you're gonna be the ten-mile call today
and get that guy too and I would say
this is a way to get you out of the
cockpit and up and out and we would it
probably a hundred different tricks and
hundred different ways to give a guy
something to think about hey this is
where you get wrapped up and this is a
tool and a technique that you can use to
take yourself out of being too attached
and to detach ten-mile call is an
awesome way to do that and engage call
is an awesome way to do that anything
that you could help with that guy and
the debrief because these are good guys
these are guys you built really strong
in ten weeks is a long time to share a
lot of space and a little space somebody
you've got to know these students really
really well you could have really honest
straightforward conversations you could
build really good relationships they
would come over on Saturdays you
barbecue and you just talk flying and
you could tell them all the things and
you wanted them to succeed and you would
give them everything you could you could
to help them get better and what did you
call this recall recall can you tell me
what happened yeah which is the massive
indicator for I'm detached and I'm
actually paying attention to everything
that's going on 100% if you are not
detached you will not you won't know
what's happening other than maybe what's
happening inside your cockpit but Top
Gun isn't about just you and your
airplane that's you leading a formation
of 16 planes and you need to know what's
going on with all those 16 plates no
different and I'm not saying that you
have to know every step that they're
taking every turn then they're me you
know there are times that you were
detached from your tasking and their
maneuvering but you know what's
happening these guys are shifting to
this building these guys are heading up
to the roof these guys are bogged down
there's a problem over here hey I need
to now pull some resources over here cuz
there's no resistance over here these
guys are kind of doing nothing and shift
them up and that you can ran as your
task unit in real time and have a really
good idea of what's going on with all of
them without being with any of them and
in the exact same way that's completely
trainable
does um does athlet how much does
athletic ability play a role you know I
don't I don't know if anybody has ever
that I've ever seen like the connection
between that specifically but if you're
a good athlete you were probably a good
pilot
and if you you were a good pilot you
were probably a good athlete and we used
to say all the time
the joke would be when people are asking
should this guy come to Top Gun the joke
would be his hey kati throw football hmm
that's the question we'd ask and it was
a little bit tongue-in-cheek because I
don't really care if you can throw a
football but it was the connection
between those those two things and it
doesn't mean how to be a superstar
athlete but you had to be athletic it's
physical its physical you had to be
athletic you had to be physical you had
to be you you had to not be afraid to
conflict and did I care if you were the
captain of your football team and
Highland nobody cared about that stuff
but there was an absolute connection
between being athletic and liking
athletic competition and being good in
the airplane how about how about
eyesight which I know back in the day
was like the component chuck yeager you
know could like PID yeah yeah Bogey's
just so before anyone was even close to
seeing him same thing I know you I know
you have really good eyes I do I I and I
did at the time I had I had really
uniquely good eyesight I mean I was
picking off I could see things in the
eye chart that were really good back and
certainly back in the day that was
everything because the only resource
they had to find the enemy was their
eyeballs but I would tell you that it's
still really important eyesight was
really important now one of the major
discoveries that the military came up
with in recent decades was that they
would let you wear glasses so you know
if you did have good eyesight they would
let you fix it but eyesight was really
critical because there's a phase in
every fight that transitions from the
systems to the visual and that
transition was really hard it's really
hard to look at your screen and then
look up and try to account for where
that person is in space clouds and all
sorts of different things and so the
sooner you could see that with your eyes
the better you know technology's help
without a bunch there's cues now little
boxes and you can do that eyesight still
important
it's not as important as it was before
but it was something that if you if you
had if you had good eyes and could
determine what's going on at far the
ranges you'd have an advantage
how much does luck play a role luck
plays role it does I'm a beneficiary of
a ton of good luck you know after my
entire life you know and there's a bunch
of cliches and catchphrases about what
luck really is luck by itself would
never would never be enough just getting
lucky and and you know that you'd come
back and man we got lucky on that one
but typically the lucky things that
worked out you can almost always connect
it to a whole bunch of things you did
right to get to the point where some
things just work out in your favor so
yeah do you guys get lucky that I get
yeah I got lucky all the time but rarely
was that by itself an attribute or a
circumstance that was very reliable can
you utilize okay so in jiu-jitsu and
really in any endeavor you can you you
can wear someone out like when judges
you call it gassing up I I would imagine
that that is a strategy that you would
have hey I've got a bigger gas tank than
you or I can make you do the new vers
that are gonna burn more gas is that a
thing yeah dude no it's totally the
mig-29 was notoriously bad on gas
notoriously you know what the next Worst
airplane for gasses 15 the f-18 so we
knew going into our fights that we're
always at a disadvantage
and when bigger planes showed up like we
talked about the su-27 that thing had a
ton of gas it's a hundred percent of
consideration a hundred percent and you
think you would think about it all the
time not to mention in naval aviation
you got to go back to the ship
you are always managing your gas you had
enough yet had enough gas to go back and
get back aboard the ship not some giant
airport with you know 18,000 feet of
runway you had to go back and land
aboard the carrier and that was a gas
critical endeavor how many yeah how many
carrier landings do you have maybe
fortune 50
dude he seems like a lot it it's not
that much but you know they're a carrier
guys out there with eight nine hundred
landing some some close to a thousand so
it seems like a lot but there's plenty
of guys with a lot more than me did you
ever were you ever comfortable with it I
got comfortable during the day for sure
to be totally honest I never got
comfortable with the night landings
never got to look got that comfortable
when I did Afghanistan right after 9/11
we were on that we were the night
carrier so all of our operations for
about six months were at night just by
pure just doing it every single day it
got a lot better but the night landing
was always in the back of your mind it
was always something to kind of contend
with psychologically that you knew that
was out there uh this is the first time
reading reading Dan's book was look I've
been told a thousand time a postage
stamp and all these other things and you
know it's so hard it's the hardest thing
and blah blah blah this book was the
first time I really said to myself yeah
it has got to be a gut check every
single time yeah look I've done a decent
amount of flying a phone a bunch of
different airplanes I got to fly with
all the services a night carrier landing
there's really nothing else like it and
it is a gut check and it was a gut check
every single time no matter how many
you've done I got well over a hundred
night landings which on a ratio of day
to night like that's not a lot of night
landings six I happen to be on a night
carrier which most deployments you don't
spend the entire deployment at night and
I just happen to be on one of those it
is it's a gut check for everybody the
pilot the flight deck the LSO the ship
then the night page on a ship on an
aircraft currency there is nothing in
aviation like it and it does a gut check
for everybody and it never gets better
and never gets easier
so talk talk me through a little night
carrier landing I will yeah night
carrier landing is is kind of the great
equalizer in in naval aviation that's a
thing that's out there that every
fighter pilots gonna have to do
and no matter what has gone on in your
mission whether it's just a straight-up
just super simple training mission you
could've been by yourself just flying
around or you just did six hours in Iraq
or Afghanistan or somewhere else you're
gonna come back and you're gonna land
aboard the ship and no matter what
you've got going on that that always
sits in the back of your mind
you got a plan for it you gotta count
forward you got to manage a fuel for it
and you've got to recognize that more
than likely the hardest part of your
flight no matter what you're doing more
often than not it's gonna be the last
thing you do when you're coming back to
the field and you know you're coming
back to Marine Corps Air Station Miramar
or wherever you're not even thinking
about the landing that's just a no but
it's just a no-brainer
landing a regular plane on a regular
runway most of the time it's just it's
just not hard it's just it's and it's
certainly not something you're gonna
sweat like man I hope I can hope I can
land this time like it's just not
something you think about so once you
figure out a land an airplane like a
like an f-18 and a regular runway you
just don't really think about it too
much
carrier is totally different and so it's
something you have to think about you
got to compartmentalize you got to
detach from it but you can't ignore that
it's out there either
so you got to think about your fuel you
got to think about your wingman you got
to think about the other twenty
airplanes that are gonna be landing on
the ship at the same time as you and the
coordination goes along with that and
this is a huge choreography that you the
ship and the other airplanes have to
manage and coordinate and typically
typically the goal is to do it either no
comm or min come there's very little
talking going on in this coordination
you might get to sign an altitude and
you might get a sign what's called a
push time when you commence your
approach and that may be all the talking
you get up until the time that you're
about to land so you're kind of alone
you're self-contained and you've got to
manage all these things so night
landings are look man they're legit and
they never get easy they never get
comfortable the the idea I've said this
before right when people say hey what
makes this seals good well I think the
thing that makes the seal
good is that we have to work in the
water and the water is the same thing
that's an equalizer every every time
you're in the water you don't need an
enemy to kill you and you're in the
water you can the water itself can kill
you when you have to do a mission over
the beach swim in you know it's your
weapons covered in sand your radios get
flooded there's all there's just all
these things that happen doing it doing
a direct action mission from Humvees
compared to doing a direct action
mission that you swam over the beach
it's not even comparable I you could
train you know you could take a high
school football team and you could train
those guys in three or four days to do a
pretty decent job doing a direct action
mission and they didn't they'd be able
to pull it off to get them to be able to
come over to launch from a ship and take
zodiacs over the beach and get on the
beach and change out into their new gear
and I you you you'd meet months you need
months if not longer you need you need
six months and you'd have a washout rate
you'd have people that are not capable
cuz look on a football team how many
people on a football team the whole team
what high school yeah let's go college
100 105 105 told olya okay so a hundred
five that are gonna train to do a land
direct action mission you're gonna have
five or six that can't do it you know
there there there they got some issue
they're not safe they're just not with
it whatever whatever the case may be you
put them in the water and you start
swimming over the beach you're looking
at your little you're losing 50 percent
of those guys maybe 70 percent of those
guys that are just they can't they're
not good enough swimmers they're not
good enough you know at in the water
they're not comfortable they're cold
there's so many things that right there
is the difference and when I start
thinking about landing on aircraft
carriers it's got to be somewhat similar
because the weather you're landing on a
thing that is
movie yeah dude it's it that's so true
man I mean I think the thing about the
water is when you're operating around
the water you can never you can't take a
timeout you can't pause you can't just
stop for a minute look if I'm coming
back to Miramar and there's a problem in
Miramar I got ten other airports within
30 minutes that I can go to I can go
back over to Yuma where the weather is
always perfect
I can go to North Island I could go to
LA I've got so many different options
and the the water never lets you pause
you cannot pause you can't just wait you
can't just decide not to do it
there's no divert that's just down the
road this this awesome
seal captain who was a prior marine and
uh and and ER and a little bit of a
rebellious guy he gave a speech that I
was at and I don't want to give any
details about where was out of what was
it about but he he was making a dig at
some of the other personnel that that he
was working with at the time and we he
said it was a great speech he was saying
look we're in the Navy and what's
different about the Navy is we come from
ships and on a ship you don't have any
choice but to fight there is no retreat
on a ship those are our routes
now look he took the most absolutely
romantic view that that the most heroic
view that a human could ever take about
tying you know the modern Navy and
especially the SEAL Teams to routing our
character in the fact that on a ship
there is no retreat
there is no surrender if the ship goes
down we all die that's our attitude I
mean you want to talk about a young jock
of it getting pumped up but fire that's
it that's what I'm thinking right now is
when you're at sea you can either land
on this carrier or you can land on this
carrier that's it I mean that's it there
is no other options yeah and if you got
a problem or you're running low on gas
or you've got a guy got a mechanical
issue that that's it's gonna create some
problems for you you
going back to the ship I mean if you're
if you take your seals and you load them
up and into into boats and you jump off
the bigger ship to go do some sort of
insertion and the weather is so bad and
the environments so bad and then
everything like hey we can't do this
training exercise it's not safe the
training exercise is canceled
what do you have to do yeah where you
got to go drive those boats into the
well deck shipping 12 foot seas which is
a complete nightmare you're not in a
parking lot thinking this was a bad idea
we can't do this and and you know the
weather is not gonna allow this this
training mission happen believe me we
are we would say you know what let's
just go totally it's easier than trying
came back oh that's yeah yeah and so the
thing about carrier landings is there's
really there's no there's no training
and there's no real life it's just real
life all the time and there's another
thing there's a psychological component
about the ship that kind of room it it
reminds you what it is every time so you
get you're coming back you may be over
the beach and you know you've done a
long mission or it doesn't matter what
you're doing at some point you end up
what's called the stack and all the
stack is is about 15 20 miles from the
boat at every altitude you know 5,000
6,000 7,000 there's an airplane in every
altitude and they just stack them up
from 5 up to however many there are up
to 20,000 feet if there's 15 there plus
something like that and you just sit in
the stack and you've got your gas and
somebody will come up in the radio and
go hey you know aircraft 204 your push
time is time 10 15 Roger that's the only
call you're gonna get so I'm at 9,000
feet I look at my watch I look at the
clock and I am now wait until 10:15 for
me to push and then there's a very
particular route and a particular
heading and turns and out and there's a
whole sequence that we all memorize how
to do it and it's not that complicated
but you got to do it but the entire time
the entire time as you're looking out
you can't see anything it's just dark
it's just pitch-black every now and then
there's like a nice moon the water has a
little white reflection of the moon
which looks kind of cool but you can't
see the ship when you're 20 miles from
an airport you see the airport you see
the runway lights you see the lights
that line you up you see the white
lights you see the control tower you can
see your buildings when you're 20 miles
from the ship you can't see
anything and then when you're ten miles
from the ship you still can't see
anything and then you just send down and
you do this the last bit of this
approach at night is it like 600 feet
over the water and it's pitch black and
you're just going towards this you 100%
instruments a hundred percent
instruments and you know and look modern
airplanes have great instruments they
horn it is a beautiful instrument to
instrument instrument and machine I'm
sure you know when yank was talking
about back in the Vietnam era is is more
challenging but you're just flying your
instrument more challenging because
homeboys up there with a red lens
flashlight trying to figure out where
he's at you had that sorry he's telling
us yards above the looking for the rake
of the ship crazy you chuckled cuz
you're asking you know like hey I think
I know that flashlight it's the same
flash I had at my flight it's the same
green elbow shaped flashlight we all
have I mean it's one thing that hasn't
changed much in naval aviation it's the
gear it's all the same stuff but as
you're coming back you're on instruments
you're waiting for your turn for the
final approach you know the last mile of
descent where you go from from 600 feet
and then you start to descend down onto
the boat itself and that's when you
start picking up the visual cues the
meatball they call and kind of the line
of the runway but a lot of times you
still can't see the ship if there's
cloudy or foggy or low or rain or snow
and all these things and all these
elements are just there and you have no
choice you have no alternative and the
psychological component of knowing that
every single time you're gonna sort of
duel with that it's in in some ways it's
it's kind of terrifying but in other
ways it means that every single there's
there's a challenge in every single
flame and I think one of the cool things
about being around the ship and one of
the things that makes Naval Aviation
unique what these guys in the Navy and
the Marines that did it is that every
single flight there was this risk
there was this fight that you were gonna
get the duel against this machine this
boat this thing that's out there that's
sort of geared and designed in every way
shape or form it's a really bad airport
it's not it's not designed to be an
airport it's got this tie in it and the
margin of error is miniscule I think in
the horn at the margin of error from
coming across they called the ramp
that's the very first piece of steel
that you get over the top of the ship to
land if you were eight feet off you're
either gonna miss and go around or if
you're eight feet low you were gonna hit
the ship so the margin of error is tiny
uh hold on a second what about what
happens when you're in a 12-foot sea
State yeah well when you're in a 12-foot
sea state and that thing is moving
around the the visual sent indications
on the ship that this visual thing we
call it the meatball just a light system
that reflects where you are so if the
light is high above there's like a green
light that goes back and forth around
yellow light in the middle it's round
it's yellow so they call it the meatball
looks like a circle if that ball is
above the green lights you're high and
if that ball is below the green light
you're low and you're kind of flying it
around to try to move that white or that
yellow ball in between the green lights
that system keeps up with ships movement
up to some degree I don't remember
exactly what it was
the ship will kind of list back and
forth it'll raise up and down and as
long as it's not moving too fast or too
much that light system is accurate oh so
you're you're you're accommodating the
movement of the ship absolutely a
hundred percent and you're moving your
throttle let you know forward and
backwards you know 1015 times every
second to accommodate for that and the
good thing is is that it's it's good
information it's trustworthy so if the
ball is high your height the ball as low
as your low the ball gets too low it
turns red you're good you are
dangerously low and that gives you a
very good cue if the ship starts moving
too fast or too much that system is no
longer reliable it doesn't keep up with
a movement in the ship fast enough so
you cannot rely on that and then your
landing signals officers your LSO so
your people that have radios on the
flight deck they have to start talking
to you and they'll say things like
ignore the information that you're
seeing you're low and now you're in this
challenge of seeing this visual cue that
you've relied on hundreds of times and
you have someone saying ignore that info
Meishan I'm telling you you need to add
power even though that's showing you hi
and look those things don't happen all
the time how can they give you the micro
adjustments fast enough in that
situation the LSO's and look I one of
the cool things once you like power
power power power break break break
break left left left is he doing that
not not it's quite as fast as you but
that is what he's that's what we were
saying so I was in Ella so one of the
cool things in my career when I was on
the ship is I got to lead an LSO team so
I was a landing signals officer so every
fifth day on a cruise I just help
airplanes land I sat out there with a
team on radios and usually usually if
Jocko is coming in these low I can just
say little power that's all you need
just a little cool smooth call and you
okay I'm behind and you'll add some
power sometimes a power and you're like
dang and you're hearing and you'll and
that's it a little more little heat no a
little big more of a hitter than you
might normally eat there are a few times
and every Ella soleus listening to this
and every student that's out there in
flight school probably knows this there
are times in my career that I've had to
scream power power power power and
barely barely got these airplanes over
the ramp to the point that after they
landed we'd go investigate and we'd see
divots on the very edge the carrier
called the round down divots from the
hook smashing the edge of the boat which
means that they're thinner their wheels
may have missed it by no joke two feet
something like that so what you describe
doesn't happen very often but it
absolutely does happen and then other
times say hey you're you're lined up a
little left it was a right for lineup
right for lineup and you're talking to
them and the the tone of your voice and
the rate at which you say it
hopefully solicits the response now the
interesting thing about that is what do
you think the mental state is of a pilot
who's solo and can't assess that on his
own to respond to your accuse you're
typically dealing with the guys who are
so they were struggling behind the
airplane and so they didn't always
necessarily respond to your calls
they didn't detach that omits that's the
challenge of the night carrier landing
can you detach from what is can be by
itself under the best circumstances a
terrifying experience under the best
nights and when you have engine problems
fuel leaks hydraulic issues low on fuel
no diverts to in the morning in a
snowstorm you have no choice but to get
aboard that ship and it does that is
that is why the carrier landing
especially the night landing that is the
great equalizer in aviation and here and
yank talk about it and reading about it
there isn't there's nothing else in the
world like it there's nothing I've ever
done that I can compare that experience
to and you did you said you did 100
night carrier landings yeah I'm a
sketchiest one dude so I mean I have I
have landed in what we call zero zero
I've landed where there is zero visible
visibility yep and what's the other zero
so the two measures is is the height of
the clouds and the depth of which you
can see them so you know a hundred and a
half would be clouds are 100 feet
visibility is a half a mile so 0 0 is
the clouds are at 0 feet and your
visibility is zero feet so you can kind
of picture being in fog it may be on the
ground maybe at 0 feet but it's thin fog
so you kind of maybe see a mile in front
of you you know driving a car and I've
never been in a car we're like dang I
can't see I can't see 10 feet in front
of me that's zero zero so you landed in
zero zero zero so here's how here's how
that works and here's how much fun that
night 0 0 landing is you can fire into
the meatball you can't see anything
zero zero you see nothing it's so yeah
these are good times so you got your
instruments though and your instrument
was thinking they wanted to be a fighter
pilot just during the Air Force bro yeah
I don't want none of this
if you're gonna fly fighters in the Navy
you need to know what you're getting
yourself into because you're gonna have
your knight in the barrel there's not a
pilot there's not a naval aviator in the
world that hasn't had that night
whatever that night is for you you're
gonna have that night and I'll bet you
the exact same thing in the teams like
you're gonna have an experience you can
have something that happens to you you
not avoid it's gonna be your night or
your day or your experience you're gonna
have that there's no getting around and
we call everybody in naval aviation
calls it the night in the barrel
that's your night and you know you don't
know what's gonna happen it's just your
night to deal with whatever you got to
deal with that's zero zero landing your
instruments we'll get you to about maybe
a quarter mile at best maybe a half a
mile so buy the last eight seconds once
you're inside that last eight seconds
your instruments just aren't they don't
keep up with what's going on fast enough
for you to fly off them you have to
transition to a visual landing you have
to and the only way for that to work
when you can't see is for you to turn on
your taxi light which is this giant
really high-powered light in your nose
gear and the LSO and this is a call you
want to have your stomach drop when
you're out in the stack with nothing
else to do but thinking about your
landing don't you hear all he says he
says he comes on the radio 99 which
means everything when you say 99 that's
a call for everybody 99 taxi lights on
well-known every pilot in the sac is
like oh god it's so bad that I I now
know that at the end of this landing I
will not be able to see the the carrier
and the LSO is gonna have to talk me
down and you talk about trust and
relationships and putting your life in
somebody else's hand you're gonna fly
this machine doing 140 knots this 35,000
pound machine to a half a mile from the
carrier and you'll never see the ship
until you hit it and the guy on the
ground is gonna talk you through the
last eight seconds of that and he's only
gonna do it through his eyeballs
literally through his eyeballs and the
faint through the fog that faint little
glow of the white light coming from your
ear nose gear and that is the UM
recalling that as we speak that is a
that's a life-changing event right there
I mean that's a that's a no-joke
experience so so he's giving you the
same things
he's eyeball eyeball he's eyeball
caliber and he'll trains this guy well
how does he know when to do this well
Ellis
LSO qualification of the Navy is
typically reserved for the best guys in
the squadron typically not always but
it's a it's a it's a very highly thought
of quality it's a it's a well respected
qualification then I'm gonna take Jocko
we're going on cruise you've
demonstrated as a young guy as a nugget
you you're good around the ship you're
reliable I'm gonna task you with
learning to be an LSO I'm gonna put my
pilot's life Sander your hands I would
do that a squadron commander I'm gonna
send you to school to be in Ellis oh and
you'll go LSO training and then you'll
go through kind of an apprenticeship
where you sit and watch other LSO's and
after about three or four months of that
I'm gonna give you the radio and on a
perfectly clear gorgeous blue day I'm
gonna let you start to see what it looks
like and you know you're you're doing it
hundreds of times a day every five days
cruise after cruise after cruise and
eventually you build this capability
through your own experience to be able
to do that do they ever have to call in
like the cooler let they're like hey man
it's zero zero go get the ice man over
there or whatever bring him up here dude
that's no joke we call him the CAG LSO
so on the ship the air group is known as
the CAG so that's you know the ship is
the ship and they've got all their
people and then the air wing is all the
planes there are two guys that are the
two senior landing signals officers on
the ship
90% of the time all the noonas training
us and letting us run the show well when
it's zero zero the cooler is the CAG LSO
and he's gonna be supporting her backed
up by the team leading and so that guy
on those nights he's gonna be the
primary controlling LSO he seemed to do
it one doing the talking and his backup
is gonna be the team leader of that LSO
teams there's five team leads so you
know five teams one for each day you
rotate every five days those two guys
the CAG also the cooler and the team
lead are gonna recover every airplane on
the ship when it's when it's required
are you answering
aye sir you're coming in zero zero and I
tell you power what do you say Roger
nope I don't you don't talk at all you
know do what he says and so and I can
tell by watching your aircraft is you
can also hear it you can so you're a
quarter-mile away you're seven eight
seconds from landing when I say power or
when I say power and you add power your
motors are gonna change you're gonna
hear that you're gonna hear the tone of
that you're gonna that he did it and you
can hear the duration and so if I say
power and you you add it and it's not
enough I'm gonna immediately say it
again before I even watch you settle
because I know you didn't do it long
enough and I'm gonna say power power and
that means you're gonna go longer and if
you go too long and I hear you really
run the engines I'm gonna say easy with
it I'm gonna ask you and you're gonna
bring power off and so I'm gonna talk
I'm gonna watch this is uniform Pro
words used by all every single word in
the LSO manual is exactly the same
people there we only use one word for
power only one word for takeoff power
one word to turn right one word to turn
left and then predetermined they all
know everybody else only uses the exact
same GZ buddy what is it easy with it
easy when that's the that's the
terminology in the book easy with it
means back off power a little bit that's
right
if you're gonna have someone go right
you say right for line up if you can
have someone go to the left you say come
left that way if you said come left come
right you might get a little cannot sure
right for line up left flounder you
might so there's a different version of
going right and then R is going left
every pilot in the world and every LSO
knows in the world he's gonna go left
come left if you wanna go right right
for line up and as I started here the
row I know he's telling me right for
line up because I don't have to really
decide for that call and if I hear the E
in the easy with it I'm coming off the
power a little bit and so there are you
know the terms are totally predefined
everybody knows what they are and we
rely on those and so the zero zero
recovery doesn't happen all that often
but it happens you can't see the ship
until you hit it yeah a zero zero
landing you may get lucky that a half a
second before you feel the shudder of
hitting the flight deck you might catch
something out of the corner right and
meanwhile at that moment you go prepare
to go full you actually go full throttle
when you hit the deck right you feel
you're your flight when you hear your
tires hit the flight deck you go full
power
[Music]
that way if you miss you're taking off
you're not just phone in the dress
that's right that's exactly right if you
miss you go back to Rosetta and you know
that lso piece of flying around the ship
is also a skill that it's really hard to
get people to appreciate how how good
you have to be how much confidence is in
LSO you have to be to say I got this III
would a thousand times over
like prefer to be the guy that's the
pilot and not to be the guy that's you
know it's one of those horrible
situations when you're not actually in
danger but you've got someone that's
relying on you to get it right yeah
you'd be a good LSO because you also
know the power you talk about all the
time of just how you communicate the LSO
is that panic when you're when I look up
and I see your jet in a really bad spot
a really bad spot and if I panic in my
communication to you now it doesn't mean
I won't be Stern and very specific power
but if I panic
and I have a high pitch kind of a shrill
town I'm communicating you're gonna
react that way so the best LSO's or the
guys that will look at the worst
situation in the most dire circumstances
and the worst weather with a pilot that
he knows has one chance to get aboard
one chance and he has the coolest comest
most chill voice in the world - OH -
you're a little low just a little power
you're on glide slope and that can put a
pilot of these to go oh holy cow I can
do this I can get a board now whereas
before he's thinking I can't see the
ship I got this engine problem I got all
these things and creates a situation his
mind that he knows he can't get a board
and LSO can talk him out of that mindset
and get him on the flight deck so when
when Dan was talking about the guy that
missed 12 times in a row and I think it
wasn't it Dan that actually went down
there and said let me get on the radio
let me talk this guy on and that's the
same thing he says hey bud we're gonna
get it done we're gonna get done right
this time yep and and if it's from the
right person at the right time in the
right way it makes all the difference
and that was that guy's night in the
barrel I mean that's a lot that's not
common
the reason you don't get another shot is
because you're out of fuel
don't you have a refuel up there yeah
usually you do there are emergencies
that your jet will not take gasps you've
got emergencies that you got a hydraulic
problem that even if you had all the
fuel in the world eventually your
hydraulic fluid will run out and you
can't fly the airplane so in most these
are not common cases but there are cases
that this happens what do you do if you
are out of hydraulic fuel you missed
your landing what's the protocol to
eject now what do you do you go into a
certain spot
do you they spin up they get the
helicopters ready that's exactly right
so there's two options you've got a
barricade option but if it's not a
controllable situation I mean the saying
is you pull alongside the ship and eject
so what you do is you try to fly a
parallel straight right across a you
know aboard the ship you know a Mahalo
beam the helicopters out there spinning
there's always a helicopter flying while
you're coming aboard at least during the
day and I've never I've never been on a
cruise where we had to intentionally do
that I've been on cruises where we
started briefing that option as a nella
so like okay here's what we're gonna do
this is what our plans are started
coordinated with the ship's emergency
recovery team on this is what we're
gonna do if indeed we don't you know get
this guy aboard for whatever reason life
of the ship is no joke and the Navy
makes it look easy because they're doing
it hundreds of times a day every single
day and 99 times out of 100 999 out of a
thousand these dire situations they pull
it off and the only ones we ever hear
about are the ones that it really but
these type of things happen all the time
these dangerous situations are happening
right now there's there's someone in the
someone in the barrel once a day on the
auto carrier deployment yeah yeah once a
days no I'd say more often than not
certainly when weather is good I mean
it's bit smooth I mean you're putting a
hundred and twenty aboard and you know
launch and recovery in a day and most
days just go by but if you've got you
know if you did the math that we've got
multiple carriers deploy to see all the
time and you're doing multiple flight
ops all the time once a week out there
somewhere in in the blue ocean there's a
kid up there who's struggling it might
not be 12 you know but he's struggling
and he's having
hard time and you're watching him have a
hard time and you're trying to talk him
down
did you ever have a hard time did you
ever get shook to the point where you
came back and like had to decompress and
say you know what this I had a I had a
buddy in this in the teams and he did a
he did a he was doing some will just say
maritime operations off the coast of
Korea for an exercise and it was just
freezing cold and claustrophobic in the
whole nine yards and and he was telling
me you know he's in this evolution and
he's thinking himself I don't even know
if I actually ever want to do this again
you know what I mean anything about that
so wait like when that kid and you know
the kid that Dan talks about the does 12
12 tries to make it the next day they
put him right back up there and he did
fine did you ever get shook as they say
in modern terminology I struggled in the
beginning before I would go watch I had
a real problem in the very beginning
when I got assigned to a carrier
squadron and I kind of had to come to
grips that this is gonna move my
day-to-day life I think I might even
mentioned it too I think I mentioned the
name Gunny pillar and being just this
awesome gunnery sergeant that taught me
everything is a lieutenant he and I were
pretty tight and I'd say for the first
probably the first month of my carrier
career where I'm doing sustained cyclic
carrier operations if I was I would walk
up on the flight deck I would pre-flight
my jet and I would throw up over the
side of the ship just from nerves and
anxiety and just like man just being
stress and I would just I would just be
physically ill and you know I didn't
tell anybody about it and he knew and so
if he ever managed to find this guy
he'll tell you those stories and it was
just something I just I just had to
learn to deal with but you know you made
up I don't mean it like the phrase man
up we call getting into an airplane
Manning up like you climb up the ladder
to man up your jet we manned up the Jets
and you go and you'd come back and then
at the end you'd look back and like that
was all
and then we just had to go to again you
you get nauseous and that's subsided I
did have a couple of landings and he
described it really well I had a couple
landings that were so kind of terrifying
that I couldn't move I couldn't control
my legs so my legs would they would
shake so so fast and so your feet would
would from the adrenaline that it'd be
hard to steer the airplane and a couple
of times I had to stop the airplane and
the flight deck group kind of
understands this like um when you just
stop to kind of look at you and you just
you kind of give them like give me a
second I had so she's after you you
hooked onto the hook you come to a stop
you kind of turn off and that adrenaline
wash kind of goes out so maybe about a
minute after that your whole body will
convulse like your legs and you see
everything with your legs so you're
putting a lot of pressure on your feet
in your toes and you maneuver the
airplane with your feet and your legs
are shaking so hard that you literally
can't steer and they're there your
margin for like they take it to the side
and ship like a three feet away from the
edge of the ship so you're looking over
the water and you're just kind of so
I've had several landings or after I
landed I needed to stop for a second and
just like hey dude just give me a second
I would just stop the airplane and
usually they would look at you and go
take catch your breath I never got out
of the airplane
and said I don't want to do that anymore
even on and I had some pretty rough
nights and I think there was just this
piece of this idea that it's like you
once said something a long time ago then
I just laughed that I'm like that's not
me and you you said I liked the taste of
blood you like and I kind of - like you
like fighting nothing you want a fight I
don't mean it like you like to fight
other people but that feeling that you
get you like that feeling well I told
you like I don't like to taste the blood
flying a fighter around the ship with
all the things that made me think about
not wanting to do it all the danger all
that emergencies all I loved it I
freaking loved every second of it even
the things that I hated and there were
things I hated about it I loved it and I
loved doing it and and I hated it at the
same time but not once did I ever
say I don't want to keep doing that how
am i as a career went on later on but
being around the ship being on the ship
doing ship things as much as I hated it
my squadron was tell you Dave did not
like flying around the ship I hated it
man I freaking loved it so that was kind
of my personal experience everybody's
different I never really quite
normalized to it always just felt like
man this sucks
but there was something about it that
never got old and never got tired for me
and I I loved doing it yeah and it's
weird because that idea of I like to
taste the blood it's one of those things
where when I haven't tasted blood in a
while I don't really I don't notice I'm
not sitting there thinking about it
and then all of a sudden something will
happen something will will will happen
wet you know could be any number of
things it could be it could be something
as simple or not not usually jujitsu to
me isn't isn't this type of thing maybe
occasionally they'll be something will
happen on the mats but normally that's
not it I just enjoyed you just do too
much but something will happen some some
situation will unfold and I'll go into
will like war mode and when I go to war
mode I I just feel so good and when I
get there I'm like oh yeah
and it makes me you know sometimes I
when I get there it makes me just look
around and I just think I wasn't really
I wasn't really supposed to be doing
anything else you know I wasn't really
supposed to be doing anything else
I was supposed to be doing that that
thing because it makes me feel so so
good
to be in that mode to feel that focus to
have like for me and this is just so
weird for me because you know I like to
I you know we're we're we're building
relationships we're building teams we're
working together for me when I have an
opponent not just an opponent it has to
be strong
when I have somebody or some entity that
that isn't that is that is antagonistic
to me and my family my friends my team I
feel something that is the best feeling
to me and it and it doesn't happen that
much anymore I mean it just doesn't I
mean that's just the way it is but like
even you know even when I was a platoon
commander and something would happen
some some other you know whether it was
whether it was the enemy whether it was
some part of some organization you know
some person that had some dude did
something that was no I want to throw
this word out there because it just it
just sets off a whole bunch of you know
what could it be but you know if there's
a betrayal scenario where someone
betrays me and they want to go to war
with me that delivers me you know that's
when I I i love the taste of blood and i
and i can feel it and you know like i
said it's it's uh you know it's an old
man talking now and just don't get those
situations very often but it's good it's
good it's a good feeling yeah it happens
from time to time well it's it's you and
I are two old men at least for this game
at this point but if I were to look back
and I spend a lot of my life dreaming up
being a fighter pilot a lot of my life
was spent dreaming about doing the
things that I got to do if you were to
ask me at any point during my time at
sea flying what I was doing that I could
have done anything anywhere for any
amount of money there's not one single
thing in the world
I would have done you know on my worst
night on my scariest whatever not one
other thing and when you said what you
said that that I think described that
feeling
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
and every night the thing that you were
fighting you know in some sense was
yourself but it was that environment
that is sort of designed to kill you
it's dark it's pitch-black at night and
it's a steal unforgiving ship with a
tiny little area that's 42 feet wide and
130 and everything about that on paper
is designed to kill you and the only way
you're gonna outmaneuver that is is what
you and your machine do and there was a
piece of that fight which I think is
what it was is that the satisfaction of
doing that on the best days of the worst
days is really hard to recreate and
replicate and feel in other ways that
satisfaction of I did something I was
supposed to be doing and if I didn't do
it well enough he was gonna get me hurt
or killed or the people around me hurt
or killed and I haven't experienced a
lot of other things like that but it's
rare to be in a you know in a work
environment where you get that so
regularly and that's every single
landing if you take your eye off the
ball no pun intended on the most clear
perfect blue sky day then you'll kill
yourself you'll get yourself killed and
you probably heard a lot of people along
the way and there was a challenge there
that I that I I never got tired of which
was for me doing what you describe is
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
can you imagine the screaming process
that it's the de facto screening process
that we can launch I mean how many guys
are landing on a carrier today right and
that happens all the time
and this screening process and the
training process is so good that these
guys can pull this off over and over
again around the world at every sea
state day night clouds no clouds fog no
fog that's what that's what that's what
we do I mean I think you look at this
and say
it's crazy I mean it ships doing well
over a hundred a day every single day
and yeah dude what the Navy is doing
it's it's unreal man it's awesome so
with that with that does that then is
this we're okay look that the inside the
Navy inside the Navy where you cannot
surrender because you cannot give up the
ship because otherwise you all about
inside the Navy you have this list of
all the people that are in the Navy of
all the people that are in the Marine
Corps a little bit different cuz it's
just a different it's a different subset
right but the subset of Marine Corps
aviators fighter jet pilots the Navy
you're you're it's it's more prevalent
in the Navy let's face it the Delta
between a Surface Warfare Officer in the
Navy and a Navy fighter pilot that Delta
is bigger than the Delta between a
Marine Corps infantry officer and a
Marine Corps fighter pilot unless we
want to go back to World War two and you
want to see some just insane incredible
just that they're there I mean the
danger of being on a navy ship in world
war ii was just totally insane as well
so so the delta the screening process
where you get to is you end up with a
certain type of person so in the Navy
when you are going to go for the SEAL
Teams you're a certainty there's a
certain element that's there and for
lack of a better word and I think I'm
using it because Dan talked about it
there's a there's a rebellious nature
right there's someone that's going hey
look I don't care you look you don't
volunteer to go land on that freaking
postage stamp
if you hold life to be the most precious
thing there's something out there right
there's something you don't do that you
just don't do that and that's what I
like about this Top Gun mentality and
I'll call the Top Gun mentality I'll to
call it the the
the the idea that I talked about earlier
this extreme ownership mentality of like
hey I'm gonna go and make this happen
and when it goes wrong I'm gonna figure
it out and I'm gonna fix it there's a
certain breed of human that tend in that
direction and you can you because
otherwise I mean let's face it you
talking about you know landing on a
carrier at night there is a massive
swath of human beings that there's no
way in hell they'd ever want to do what
you just talked about echo what is your
are you fired up to go do a carrier
landing right now not at this stuff what
about night time the lorda barrel what
about day after day after day after day
after night after night after night
after night right so we're talking about
a different you know a different kind of
human with a different mentality and
what we've done is set up this process
that finds those humans they gets them
to that point where they do that for 25
years for 25 years that's how we're
doing this
that's pretty impressive yeah so I got I
had a couple more things I want to ask
you flexible four is that what it's
called the flexible four what's that
what's the it for the fluid four yeah
that's what a man what we're we're in a
formation we work together
it sounded like there's a lot more
regimented than it was fluid yeah fluid
four is not a fluid formation does
anyone use it anymore
yeah we use it to kind of like navigate
to and from the space other than that
it's not happen it's not a tactical
thing at all you you do it just to keep
people close together so you're here
we're gonna go from point A to point B
and I want to mess around just kind of
get close to me we're gonna fluid four
out there I sent you a text
I said loose deus I said loose deus in
equals cover and move Plus decentralized
command
and your like Roger makes sense yeah
yeah that's it exactly God yep because
no loose goose formation or sorry loose
Deus formation either one of us can take
lead we can we can we can take lead and
we can make things happen on our own and
yet we have to cover for each other yeah
if we don't work together we're gonna
die that's right that's exactly right I
can I can direct you to do something
that I need you to do and when you don't
comply I know that it's cuz you can't
and so there's this relationship piece
there's all those components that you
just talked about are inside there and
that's how you and I are gonna work
together to eventually isolate the bad
guy and one of us gonna kill them and I
don't really care who does it as long as
one of us does it and that means I gotta
stay engage the whole time that you get
the kill it's good by me cuz we're good
and we move on these guys figured that
out right these guys figured out these
guys said the other way doesn't work
this way works better this is again you
have to have some element of rebel
mentality in your brain in order to say
you know what it's same thing with say
the same thing with jujitsu right you
someone's gotta say listen I don't
really believe that if you do this kata
to me that it's gonna work somebody's
got to say that in the teams that you
know the biggest this this happened to
us and the teams we were we were using
we'd use real ammunition we'd shoot a
paper targets and you win every single
time and you've you know you go through
the house and every every target is dead
and they didn't maneuver you they didn't
fire they didn't fire on you and they
don't maneuver so it becomes so easy
when we brought in laser tag we brought
in paintball and simunition and these
things that allowed us to fight each
other even then somebody had to have the
mentality number one to say you know
what first of all we should try these
tactics on each other because we've been
being told over and over again I got
told that for my first 10 years and the
team's eight years and the teams hey
this is what works you know what you say
Roger that Roger that Roger that to say
you know what we need to check this we
need to test it you know what there was
people that win paintball when paintball
sealed the shortfalls of our tactics
there was people that said yeah but yeah
but you know it's it's only paint so
it's oh yeah but it's not a real weapon
yeah but though there's a bit different
in the penetration there's all kinds of
yeah buts the rebels said yeah you're
saying yeah but guess what somebody just
pointed a paintball gun down the hallway
and and you know 13 out of 16 of us got
hit with paintball that doesn't seem
good and there was people that were
saying yeah but yeah but it's not an
ak-47 a ak-47 only holds 30 rounds of
paintball gun it has a hopper with a
hundred rounds that's not realistic okay
what if they had a freaking any kind of
machine gun so you have to employ this
rebel mentality and that's why you get
you know that's where you get these
crazy Top Gun stories that's why they're
stealing a trailer to set up shop the
seal team has to trace its whole history
back to that kind of rebel behavior yeah
there's a there and that's what shocked
me and then shocked me but that's what
was so amazing when Dan was like hey
he's the OIC and he says we are gonna be
the most professional humans that these
pilots have ever talked to we're gonna
brief these things we're in a murder
board each other we're gonna be in the
perfect uniform they're talking about
uniforms this attitude of we're gonna be
rebellious we're gonna we're gonna make
sure things work and at the same time
we're gonna be we're gonna be aboveboard
across the board and everything else so
that when we step out and say hey this
is wrong people will actually listen
that is a rare thing it's a rare thing
to know that you have to hold the line
toe the line be aboveboard across the
board and then at the same time know
that when something's not quite right
you've got to be a rebel at heart
Top Gun mentality yeah man it's so legit
and and have that legacy persist and to
be able to cultivate it in a way that
has evolved and changed a whole bunch
we're not dealing with the same problems
that that the the original bros are
dealing with back in the late 60s we're
not losing in Vietnam we're not dealing
but we actually have to do the same
thing and what what that mentality now
is fighting against the complacency that
comes with the things that we've been
able to do so well for so long and have
people say hey listen I know this has
worked for a long time and I know this
has been the best way to do it but it's
not gonna keep working like this because
the people were fighting against are
gonna figure this out they're gonna
build a new machine they're gonna build
some countermeasure they're gonna do
something that keeps us from working and
we act to have to be every bit as
creative and not tell the or the entire
institution what we're doing won't work
anymore and figure out a way to get the
institution this giant behemoth
institution to listen to you and none of
that happens ever unless you as a leader
as a team member
stay humble if you don't stay humble I
can't even imagine like I know what the
you know when you're going to the SEAL
training and it's the most elite
training and you you know the the video
the recruiting video that I watched the
title of the video was be someone
special right that's the title of the
video to try and get you to go in there
so you're getting told you're special
the whole time the top guns got to be
ten times worse on top of that you add
the freaking you know maverick and Viper
and Iceman I mean we're talking you're
just this is an this is an ego booster
rocket and to to have that ego booster
rocket and yet you know throw out the
sea anchor to keep you grounded to keep
you down to earth to keep you humble
that is the last part of this top gun
mentality that's allowed us
you know allowed the Allies of America
are our air forces around the world to
be the best and continue to be the best
and you have to have all those elements
and what's awesome is if you have these
elements these elements do not only
apply to fight or flying aircraft they
apply to being in a sealed platoon they
apply to being an infantry company they
apply to being on the jujitsu mats they
apply to every compete to be enough in a
part of a family part of a team part of
anything these aspects will make you win
in the end
[Music]
two and a half hours Dave did I miss
anything no man that was awesome there's
probably a bunch of other things that
you could get me talking about the
mentality that you talked about at the
end I think for me is the most important
thing for sure yeah
and that's and to finish without it and
to have that be the thing that persists
in the legacy of Top Gun and have it
have nothing to do with Hollywood or any
of those things but the legacy of people
who took that burden of responsibility
of I'm responsible for people's lives
we're gonna go out and lead junior
pilots out into combat and turn that
into something that becomes an
organization that's lasted for decades
I mean what yank was able to do in the
face of more organizational resistance
than I've ever faced
I didn't face a big Navy or big Marine
Corps telling me no all the time I
didn't grow up in that that Marine Corps
to be and I said this last time but to
be a small link in that long chain I had
a harder time reading this book
personally because it was so easy
connect I was so inside not I read this
book and understood so much of it that a
hard time seeing it you can actually
even talked about a little bit of hate
what like I was missing components of
that because I was on the inside talking
about it with him last week and then
coming back here again on today
has helped me detach even more to see
even what I did at topic on while I was
there that didn't I didn't understand
quite that level because I was inside of
it and the story is incredible but it's
it's the persistence of that mentality
that is how you win everywhere connected
back to the attribute that has been my
biggest challenge and by far the thing
that has mattered the most of my life
which is humility to learn it a place at
Top Gun where people are telling you
that you're the best of the best that is
the phrase against there aren't all the
time the best of the best you know
there's a difference between humility
and showmanship there's plenty of
showmanship up there used to talk about
Conor McGregor all the time but there is
so much humility inside that
organization because of the the burden
and the responsibility they feel that
it's cool to come from a circle from the
beginning this conversation was I
learned more about humility at Top Gun
than anywhere else because it was the
thing that I was required the most for
me to actually be successful there and
yankin and the original bros hmm they
deserve a lot of credit for creating
that no doubt and it's it's also amazing
that when you trace back the history of
the SEAL Teams and the way they were
formed and the way they learned and the
attitude it's the same it's the same
traits it's the same traits that we talk
about all the time this is what it takes
to win and with that echo Charles yes do
you have any suggestions on how we can
employ the top gun mentality in our own
lives yeah sure but first I have a
question for good deal Dave so back to
the because it's kind of confusing
situation of scenario one got maybe two
scenario the one where mm things you're
going way back yeah cuz that let's face
it that wasn't as cut-and-dry
straightforward as far as understanding
it goes look just as hard to track yeah
a little bit right so okay so you're
trying to close the distance as the
the Guayana fender no okay you got it
that's right um so yeah cuz it's
confusing because usually like in
jiu-jitsu fighting the offender wants to
go if your jujitsu fighter you want to
close it yes you know yes and then that
outside green zone is not available in
this scenario but it is still available
in the whole kind of scope of fighting
okay you said that you don't do like a
like a like a juke or like a feint or
anything like that you know go one way
and then break right or whatever is
there any version of a feint in
dogfighting at all well wouldn't it be
you do a break and then you do a ditch
and then you do another break and then
you do another ditch you know I would
not equate I I did not explain it well
enough to have it in your in your mind
see it clearly enough but the break and
the ditch or two exclusive things and
the simplest way to answer that is is no
because if you're fighting against
opponent an opponent who recognizes that
that's a feint what a feint would do if
you move to one direction to set up a
movement in another direction is that
you're giving him the separation that he
wants to attack you and part of what
might be confusing about this is that
you know we started with this one
against one which is a very canned setup
that we're starting at a mile or
whatever that might be you know that
that's six thousand feet it has an
account for all the things that have
gotten to that point but that mile is
actually the optimal separation for an
attacker to get so if you were in in
whatever the optimal position between
you and somebody else in jiu-jitsu for
you to be successful as the person in
the offensive advantage that's a mile so
if you can kind of equate if you were to
just show me exactly how you'd want to
position yourself against someone else
you know you're taking his back you've
kind of started to set up the rear naked
or whatever that might be whatever that
that separation is that's not the same
separation as if someone in the mount
pulled you and kind of grabbed
you and pulled you close him so you
couldn't strike them so that that start
of you being behind him is is that start
of that position and if I kind of
fainted or kind of hinted at I was gonna
move in one direction to stop the choke
and I opened up my neck to do it yeah
the gap the guy you're fighting is gonna
laugh at that faint because all you did
was open up your neck and he's good
enough and fast enough to take advantage
of that that he what you're doing is
giving him more positional advantage
than you already have
yeah totally understand now cuz I think
it's natural one we're not fighter
pilots to uh to think oh yeah the
defender right the guy who's in front or
whatever we think of that as I get it
why doesn't he just get away right or
why doesn't you you know why don't you
just do a move here and fake them out
and get away but it's not that it's like
you the the the offender the offensive
guys just kind of trying to keep you at
a certain range right attack range like
that's essentially his goal it's not to
like follow you everywhere you know like
a high-speed car chase or something it's
like to keep you in that range the whole
time so if you compare it to jujitsu
right you know how like we have
situational training which that's
essentially what it is right situational
training so if you start on my back
Jaakko mm-hmm I'm the defender it's
essentially the same thing I'm the
defender and you hold me I hold you
tight like I'm holding your hands and
stuff like I got one hand here one hand
here I'm holding you tight you can't
like maneuver at all I'm so tight
everything is just so tight you want to
get me in a range that essentially you
can choke me
right so or actually a better one inside
control you know I think I have it I
think I have it I think I think I
figured out what's going on here you've
heard me say in jujitsu that if I'm
going to fake a move if I'm going to
feint to move I actually have to feint
the move enough that you have to react
to it yeah right
I can't just I can't just fake the sweep
and expect you to react be
if you if I faked the sweep and you know
it's a fake sweep you just pass my
garter you you you take advantage of my
fake or you don't fall for it at all I
think because of the because of the
reaction of an aircraft if you're going
to fake enough that I'm gonna actually
have to fall for your fake for you to
recover back is you can't do it quickly
enough and I am going to be able to take
advantage of it so you can't it's it's
not possible to throw a fake that's
committed and like when you commit the
the the the hands-down the best thing
you can do is commit to that move and
that is the hardest thing for me to
track is that an accurate assessment yes
yeah that took me so long to figure out
it took me this entire conversation to
figure out that yeah so like in jujitsu
they're not really even faint they're
essentially just chaining moves together
I'm gonna do this movement when he
reacts to this move that I'm doing not a
fake one a real one when you and I can
do this to do a real move yeah yeah and
let's face it if you do a real move in
jujitsu and the person doesn't react to
it well then you just get the moon so
that's what they're saying here is
you're doing the move and if the person
doesn't react to it cool you win if they
do react to it you go to the next move
in the chain there is just like you
would in jujitsu yeah yeah exactly so uh
it'll you ever been against someone
where you get side mount on them and
they hold you really really really like
just new guys I think do it out of panic
but if you get a strategic guy like some
of the graces will do this where they'll
hold you because if you're too tight
Chester you can't do any submission so
you need a little bit of space you know
so it's essentially that right where the
defender he's holding you tight that's
what he wants he wants to hold you tight
you don't start off tight but that's
that's how he can kind of defeat your
attacks because you're out of range of
attack right so it I think it's just a
misconception where Outsiders people who
are not pilots or whatever they look at
Top Gun and they're like yeah you just
shoot the guy that's how you win you
know kind of thing but
- no you got to keep them in that range
and then yeah if you can find that the
correct jiu-jitsu scenario that's that's
similar then it becomes easier to
understand because I wasn't
understanding at all
okay fraud that thing like why doesn't
loose good yeah
but then after a while I think I got it
I think I'm ready let's go up to top
guns ready for Top Gun yeah do this yeah
speaking a top gun we do want to be
capable as capable as we can you know we
don't all have 2030 vision wait which
one is the good vision twenty thirty or
thirty twenty twenty-five twenty-five
dope once once I work no superhuman the
second number is the low number
so twenty twenty means at twenty feet
the object appears like it's 20 feet
away that's normal twenty thirty means
at twenty feet the object appears like
it's 30 feet away with the fighter
pilots some fighter pilots out there
they got 2010 vision they see it as if
they're 10 feet closer that's how good
their eyes are my my daughter allegedly
allegedly they brought other you know
they when she was doing the item it's my
oldest daughter and they doing the eye
test the doctor was or the whatever the
practitioner of was her hey everyone
come in here and look at this cuz she
was just really good
she said 25 that seems unrealistic to me
but she also kind of gave like a 25 and
she was like 25 2010 so maybe it's just
2010 but yeah it's really my my dad also
had really insane vision really insane
really good vision mine was always just
you know solid real said good what did
you was yours so I was better than 20/20
yeah so like I was I would read the 2015
line kind of no factor and I was picking
off like a couple off the 2010 which is
not not common I mean not a lot of I was
lucky enough to have a gift of really
good vision yeah I mean just a man how
stoked were you when you're like they're
like oh yeah your vision because you
want to be a fighter pilot
oh by the way this is one of the most
important factors oh by the way you
happen to have just naturally one in a
hundred thousand humans have this kind
of vision can you like not become a
fighter pilot if your vision is like a
you know it used to be like that like I
said now that here I like soccer and go
get LASIK and my long as he passed the
physical is good and there's there's
technology and science out there that
improves your vision you don't have to
be born with it anymore
did you notice that on the muster video
the one that get the mustard I got
penciled Orlan Orlando right yes I got
canceled in the video put little
attributes to each of the team members
and yours with ice test it was real
quick that's why I saw that anyway
capability right all right you want to
be capable you want to stay capable
chuckle fuel will help you do that
actually here's the thing all right look
do you have a perfect diet do you have a
perfect guy no I do not I don't have a
perfect diet either so chuckle fuel food
drink supplementation boom all in one so
what do we got joint warfare super krill
oil for your joints when they go out and
then you said boom I was like oh he's
trapped I don't know he had only taken
deco knows where he's going but then you
just you just maneuvered right out of a
little deck transition and you rolled
right out and I was pretty impressed
like what is that a hard break
transition was awesome right there right
there you go nonetheless I'm just trying
to explain what we got here you know
what we're taking what I'm taking you
know anyway well just be straight up
what do you take every day super krill
oil I ran out of joint warfare just
texted me I know I know you know and I'm
14 2020 and this makes use but
nonetheless you know I got a response so
easy FedExing I you know I don't go over
those details
okay so we'll the good guy as a
percentage thing is we can we will now
get another what is that scientific
assess
when you go off join warfare yeah and
you start getting aches and pains yeah
which is what happens yeah right so you
take join warfare supercruise know that
all the combo that's that's a combo in
Santa oxidant combo right there DJ I
take three joint warfare in the morning
three joint war for at night three super
krill in the morning three super krill
at night every day yeah I think
basically after I do that but not night
in day or just do a one hit three and
three huh
easy money discipline every single day
every put it this way every day that I
work out d playing all day with like a
electrolyte kind of thing you know I
used to take this pre-workout with
caffeine don't even take it anymore
discipline so the powder like discipline
yes well flavor which all of them all
interchangeable to me cuz I she's still
up do you ice crushed ice crushed ice is
ridiculous shirt Tropic Thunder you know
is my go-to with the cans 100% drink
cans every day but the discipline powder
100% every day every day that I workout
which is five sometimes six days a week
yes so that's the everyday thing to bulk
not every day oh really that look comes
in waves mmm cousin sister you know
sometimes you just told you thought the
milk in the coconut milk right yes sir
that's a big difference because look I
can't pound a freaking half gallon of
milk or whatever I can't pound a big
giant
what is it 20 ounces of milk on an empty
stomach it's not it's not optimal as the
way you feel right yeah
your family registers but you can hammer
that coconut milk and it tastes your
freakin delicious yeah delicious
arguably better than regular milk taste
wise coconut milk with we could be there
yeah we could be there I know that some
days looking at me like I'm crazy I'm
don't know me cook there if you haven't
gone have you gone down the coconut milk
Road yeah
but I'm not I'm not a milk I we do
almond milk okay so I think you're
speaking my language I mean to drink
like 20 ounces of milk right now
actually sounds like a would be a
problem yeah and I guess I haven't drank
regular milk and a long day like at
night carrier land it would be the
bigger issues bear all what do you mean
you don't take it every day but milk
yeah yeah you know it goes in ways like
for you know week two weeks or whatever
you like if you're you what do you do
when you get done with dinner
and it was a really good dinner then
you're like oh yeah but I want dessert
yeah I don't deserve what makes it wrong
well you know when I'm thinking that
milk train all day but the thing is that
feeling comes in waves you see I mean
anyway the the almond days are not
relating at all the almond milk coconut
milk regular milk I like Reagan regular
milk straight up like like it empty
stomach full stuff whatever I had
coconut milk in like us you know on
random smoothie before and I was
surprised it was surprisingly oh it's
good for coming from a dairy milk cows
milk lover that's that's something cool
alright so we got that we got warrior
kid milk as well we got jock a white tea
we got the cans of discipline goal which
I've been partaking into quite quite a
few many today so getting a little crazy
with that and part of that reason is
just cuz it freakin tastes delicious
all these things are available at the
Vitamin Shoppe so if the vitamin shops
are open around you can find some of
this stuff if not you can go to origin
main ma IND calm you can order it up and
we will send it to you stat yep very
reliable that oh the crew is up there
just getting after it
yes just getting after it
also origin they also make Gigi's for
jiu-jitsu because we are doing jiu-jitsu
hey slow we got to get back continue to
have to at some point we have to right
and I dig it if we're if we're if we're
exercising restraint being a little
hesitant you know given the current I
dig it but some of us men it's got a
corn and train string with your
quarantine yes sir with your corn team
yeah man right and some people getting
back into it quicker than others so if
you don't have a gig want to know what
the best ski is factually Goergen key
boom in America hundred percent also
aside from jiu-jitsu not forgetting
about it but aside from jiu-jitsu we got
in addition to an editor yes correct in
addition to jujitsu keys that are made
in America we have other things yes so
that is true denim American denim in the
form of jeans yep we all wear jeans
quarantine or not we can wear our jeans
and we can represent made in America
hundred percent you by the way no big
deal but you can also help rebuild
manufacturing in the United States of
America
maybe that's important you I know it's
important to me so you might want to get
on that train as well gives yourself
some origin boots yeah boots have it yes
I do
as a matter of fact I do I don't think
I've seen you wearing them have I oh wow
no I haven't seen you wear I tend to
reserve my boot wearing scenarios pretty
conservatively you know so yeah you know
I don't basically this is your way of
saying we need to make origin just
sailors and zippers and some form of
sneakers sneakers tennis shoes running
shoes whatever whatever weird depending
on what part of the world you're from
well you guys call sneakers in in Hawaii
shoes shoes you know what I don't know
if we were ever familiar with that
product shoes or whatever to the
mainland it was like yeah she's sneakers
we wear slippers aka flip-flops yeah or
go bare feet hundred percent
what are we calling sandals yeah I call
them flip-flops yes sandals to me
sandals means has a strap over the top
is a different situation maybe this is a
like this is like a guy that lives in
Miami that's taking his you know his
young girlfriend and he's like 52 years
old and he's taking her out to like an
Italian restaurant that guys wearing
sandals right hablar well right there
did I catch maybe is there an origin
flip-flop scenario brewing here I would
not be mad at that scenario no let me
put it to you this way I don't want to
wear things that aren't made in America
so so yes and as like you I wear
flip-flops pretty much every day so are
there some brewing the answer is in the
affirmative
well I think sandals when this is just
how it feels so I don't know technically
flip-flops sandals if you're referring
to flip-flops are the ones that if
you're referring to my homeboy in Miami
yeah well that's it ready go for the if
the thing goes between your your big toe
and your second toe the thing you know
they for my songs sometimes oh it goes a
turn for if it has that then yeah
sandals don't they just cover your foot
they don't go between your till I don't
know that seems like the technical
reason all this stuff and more available
at origin main comm get some yes very
true also what do we got I think we have
a store yes it's called Jacko's store so
when you want to continue to represent
on the path is where you can get your
discipline equals freedom good shirts
more rash guards David Burke hoodies
hats beanies you know all this kind of
stuff
mmm Hara we got some posters on that -
oh yeah worry kids stuff as well that's
always good yeah yeah Jaakko store comm
go over there you know get something
represent while you're on this path that
we're all on
also you can support this podcast by
subscribing to it subscribe to this
podcast and then this podcast called
aquaponic asks we also have another
podcast that I'm changing the name of
and we'll get it back out there and I'm
we're discussing the how we're gonna
actually play that game or how we're
gonna do it but so there was a podcast
called the thread it will be back under
a new name I didn't I didn't even Google
the name when I just named my own new
podcast write this zero research this is
a good name I like it and do it so
sometimes I'm a little bit to default to
groove so god watch out for that got the
grounded podcast where we talk about
life through the lens of jiu-jitsu
warrior kid podcast for your children
and also pretty good for parents to
listen to and also get some more your
kids soap available yet yes oh it's
available on jock on store.com order
yourself some killer soap made by young
Aidan so that you as a human being can
stay clean also not to mention Jacko's
soap and trooper so oh yes so the you
know so sometimes I'm not saying this is
what it's for cuz it's not what it's for
but sometimes soap is sort of sitting
out it's just sitting out on display
we'll call it so word on the street is
the trooper soap in particular gets many
many compliments with the aroma
interests so it smells good is what I'm
saying interesting yeah I personally
like that killer so there are not killer
so but I guess the trooper soap if you
wanna you know let's say it's at night
time your final shower you're gonna go
go sleep with your wife or something
like this maybe is that you presume
that's what I'm saying interesting
anyway yes Irish also spoken wrench calm
also jaco store calm foam soap available
get some also we have a YouTube channel
if you're interested in the video
version of this podcast it'll watch it
instead of just listen by the way I
posted a video the other day of me
making some food with Josh Hall
oh yeah and Tory and
somebody wrote like the no explosions so
I think we kind of owe it to the world
explosions and some you know some Jocko
cooking videos yeah I'm the worst cook
uh well you know some guys are into it
yes you know it's kind of like a thing
like yeah I'm gonna grill up late babbit
all the way dude Lafe babbles all about
that grilling and what do you do with
the when you're doing that before you
cook it you leave it in the fridge
inside some sauce for the night what's
marinate it Mary laughs I can't move
who's Mary he's all fired up for that
it's I you know what I'll do with food
eat it yeah I understand so you know you
can tell if someone's really into
cooking when they put salt on it they
don't just put salt like this or like I
see you put seasoning you know before it
goes in the of it wherever it goes you
know you just put salt put seasoning
this is how you can tell they grab the
salt they grab the salt with their
fingers and then they sprinkle it like
in a circle you know like that but they
have a technique to sprinklings you seem
saying people not into cooking they
don't do it cancer what about the guy
that that the salt Bay
Oh advanced oh and there's the deal salt
administrator I've been to his
restaurant yeah and I have had him
actually put salt on my steak cut it for
me yeah indeedy and he did it that way I
did he was advanced name-drop you
weren't here name-drop yes sir I knew I
was sitting there eating steak with a
couple friends including hens Oh Gracie
we're kicking it yes such an awesome guy
yes sir so there you go name-drop yeah
anyway so the point is yeah we have a
YouTube channel so yeah check that out
if you're if you know you don't watch
the podcast straight up also
psychological warfare you need a little
spot that's what it is a spot if you're
heating moments of weakness specifically
in the workouts that I mean if I'm
speaking for myself right now
you need a little spot I'm gonna get
past that feeling or don't feel like
doing this whatever boom psychological
warfare will spot you a little bit focus
on canvas calm Dakota Meyer making
prints for you to hang up in your house
that will keep you on the path we
got a bunch of books we got Top Gun by
Dan Patterson you can get that on Jaco
podcast.com the books
some people were late getting that up
there no big deal yeah you know whatever
it'll eat them yeah that's what I'm
saying
you can get that that you can also get
the latest book called the code the
evaluation of protocols Dave Burke
getting some good feedback on that well
some good feedback on that book
big-time agree
troopers are in the game among this book
which is awesome humbling book humbling
and repetitively humbling repetitively
huh
it's one of those books where it's kind
of like what you were saying about
landing on a carrier and being on a
carrier and having that life where
you're like this is hard but I love it
you know that's the code the evaluation
put yourself in check and it's like a
ring or it is a reminder because like
I'm a lot of this stuff is like yeah
like you could have a one day you could
have a zero day right but if you forget
about the code it won't even really move
you either way but if you're on the Pat
you know if you're if you are reminded
that hey you're going by this code you
throw up a zero but that hurts you know
but if you're not reminded it doesn't
hurt seem sane you know remind yourself
so get the code you can get leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual you
can get way the warrior kid one two and
three you can get miking the dragons you
can get discipline equals freedom Field
Manual you can get extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership been writing books
over here get some information in yeah
check those books out and so on front is
our leadership consultancy where we
solve problems through leadership you
may think well how are you doing that no
one's traveling because a kovat 19 well
we are we are doing it all day long
we're actually stepping up we're doing a
lot of it virtually what we're doing it
all virtual now and what we found is
that you can have me come and talk to
your you you can have me come and talk
to your team of a thousand people in a
big in a big auditorium
and most of those people what they're
watching
is the screen next to me on stage that's
projecting my face that's what they're
actually watching and then they don't
have any interaction they can't ask any
question cuz there's too many people
there or during a zoom call um right
there Dave's right there laced right
there whoever whoever from the Echelon
front team is right there talking
directly to you to your team so it's
turned out awesome
you know the interaction that we can
have the connection the discussions
that's what we're doing at national on
front now it's been a great transition
I'm sure we'll do we will end up doing
live face to face consulting again but
right now it's no factor we're pushing
right through it
how many zoom calls do you think you're
doing a day right now dude I'm doing a
lot of zoom oh yeah and the whole time
in my head I was thinking what it was
it's no factor it's no factor yeah it's
been awesome yep it's it's in many ways
it's better yeah it's better to be able
to have Dave talk to your 12 person team
twice a week and that cost Dave an hour
but he spent what it cost him two hours
you know in a week
whereas if he had to fly up to your
location and spend two hours up there
that cost him whatever two days it cost
him two days and your people can't you
know hate him up in that conversation
and say hey what do you think I hate
good let me let me hit you the email
it's it's it's truly developing
relationships that we didn't think was
possible so go to echelon front comm for
details on that and in that we also
stepped up our game with EF online EF
online.com this is the other thing we're
doing we are communicating all the time
we're having live meetings we're doing
them basically five times a week if you
want to sit if you want to ask me a
question if you want to ask me a
question
if you want to
sit there all the computer look at me
and ask me a question go to EF
online.com and come to one of our live
meetings you will get to ask me a
question we'll have a full conversation
it's it's epic
not to mention we've got all kinds of
material on there too for you to to
learn leadership to train your tactics
it's all in there and it's only growing
it's growing really fast we've we're
we're pouring everything we got into EF
online so check that out we also have
the monster coming up we have Dallas
Texas December 3rd and 4th we have
Arizona Phoenix Arizona September 16th
and 17th so if you want to come to those
better register quick extreme ownership
comm we've sold out all of our gigs
we've ever done we'll sell these out too
so if you want to come go register and
EF wha over watch an EF Legion look we
work with companies all the time all
companies need leaders at every level
from frontline leaders to senior leaders
if you need a senior level level leader
go to EF overwatch if you need a
frontline leader go to EF Legion if you
were in the military in any capacity go
to EF Legion comm and go and register so
we can get you connected with companies
that are looking for frontline leaders
and finally America's mighty warriors
dot org
that is momily that is mark lee's mom
and that is her charity which she set up
after mark was killed she decided to
pick up the fight she decided to carry
on and she's out there helping service
members helping their families helping
gold star families around the world to
give you an example of what she's doing
there's medical treatments that
sometimes aren't covered by insurance
America America's mighty warriors is
covering that kind of thing for vets
she's doing it all the time that's one
of the many things that she's out there
doing so if you want to support go to
that website and you can either donate
or you can get personally involved
and if you want to hear any more of my
despotic sermons or you want to hear any
more of Ecco Charles's preposterous
myths or you haven't had enough of
Dave's overindulgent anecdotes then you
can find us all of us or on the
interwebs we're on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook Dave is at David our Burke Ecco
is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and thanks to all of the
military personnel out there look they
all make this machine work when that
carrier when that fighter pilots going
to land on that carrier there's 5,000
people that are making that possible on
that ship there's 5,000 people working
coordinating making it happen they're
all over the place so thanks to all of
you that are out there thanks to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol Secret Service
and everyone that defends our way of
life right here at home also thanks to
all the doctors and nurses and medical
personnel who care for us when our way
of life is threatened and everyone else
out there just remember to keep that Top
Gun mindset put your ego in check throw
in a little bit of rebellion push
yourself to learn set up competition
that forces you to get better and then
get out there and get after it and until
next time this is Dave Burke and Ecko
Glen Jocko